what is up guys welcome to the pre-game
i am your host sarah garvey i'm standing
in for pearl
and as you guys already know this week
um she's gone away she's on holiday you
know but if you haven't already
subscribed to the channel please do so
hit the notification bell so you know
when we're going live
and we have got a show for you today
right today
we've got what one two three four five
six people so what we're going to do
we're going to go around and see we got
with us today could you give it your
name
age
and relationship status
bradley uh 18 single
bolaji 24 single
taimika 32 in a relationship
hi i'm shimari i'm 21 and i am single
i am isabella i am 26 and it's
complicated
mirrifay five single
right today ladies and gents we are
going to be discussing
red pill rage
first of all does anyone know what the
red pill is
is there anyone
go on let's go what's the red pill no no
not for me you go okay
right my definition of red pill is
um men that have cracked the code
in terms of women and see what the game
is in terms of relationships
and they've either adapted or gone their
own way
or has like
restricted themselves from
from from women in general from the
relationship yeah so what it is
generally what the red pool is um i
don't know if anyone has heard of mgtow
men going their own way does anyone have
a manga in their own way
no no no yeah you see
ladies
you don't know that men are you don't
know that men a guy in their own way i
know the concept definitely
right so the red pill community men go
in their own way it's basically like you
know like he said it's men that have
actually said you know what they're a
little bit jaded by the dating market a
little bit jaded by women in general and
they've said you know what you know what
no we don't need women actually we'll
just focus on ourselves make ourselves
better and if we engage with women we do
and if we don't
we don't
so what i want to try and get is
from everyone why do you think
men
would be going their own way from women
is there a problem with women nowadays
well i wouldn't necessarily say it's a
problem with women it's kind of like
like today's market is more like money
is more important than like
relationships so people like kind of
rising up and like going their own way
yeah i think um social media has a big
influence on that
um
and you know the rise of all the dating
apps and
there's so much choice now for basically
women and
men don't really have as many options
i would say speaking to the mic a little
bit like men
generally don't really have as many
options as women so um
they they basically decide to go their
own way focus on themselves
build up build their life their lives up
and
yeah hopefully something comes out of it
by the end of the day they're fine
they're they've got their resources set
for them and that's pretty much it
why would men be guys always suffering
from women nowadays i think guys are
basically just taking the women's lead
because women have been doing this for
years
so that's my opinion
so women have been
going their own way going out away from
men
for years i feel like they have
hmm
i agree
you agree yeah
with that women have just been with that
statement of i think women have been
like you know the whole girl boss
feminism movement and like beyonce
independent women like i think the whole
stance of a woman being independent has
been out there for a little while now
i think it's refreshing that guys are
not doing it too
okay why why am i going their own way
i think
relationships are not worthwhile these
days like
yeah the
on on both sides i don't feel like
they're good partners so if it's not
going to be good why go for it
oh you look like you got something on
your mind over there i'm just going to
say it's feminism in it that's what it
is explain go a little bit deeper
why why would it be what why would
feminism make men go their own way
okay so i'm gonna have to break this
down
and okay because i know so much it's
like i would assume that everyone knows
what i know so it'll be it'll be easier
if people knew what i was talking about
but if i tried to break it down like
this
women
after like the revolution of feminism
and the burning of the bra and stuff
like that
uh
they've
they've they've allowed men to have sex
with them without
giving them a ring for it
so but then why would that make men go
their own way then exactly so because
right because i'm as a man now i don't
need to marry a woman
now it's the best man that gets the
woman
so now you have the the 90 10 rule so
it's like the best top 10 men get 90 of
the single women so if i'm not get if
okay i'm i'm not gonna basically
watch my
i'm just well i'm i don't consider
myself an eye but anyway i'm not gonna
watch
a friend
get all the girls he wants
because he looks cute he looks nice so
he's doing something and then that same
girl comes back after and says oh i'm
ready for you now
it's not going to happen so that's as a
man i'm i'm restricting myself from that
i'm i'm not going to allow it
so a lot of men angry
because of that most definitely
ladies have you have you have you seen
men become more angry nowadays
i wouldn't say more i feel like
the same i feel like i think i don't
feel like there's really been lots i've
noticed the change okay so people like
kevin when kevin samuel was kind of
bursting to the scene right people was
he's a red pill man yeah right and they
were saying that he's angry did you did
you not see a lot of guys
speaking the way kevin sanders was
speaking
yeah but i think they how we talked
about last time is like this is someone
that
that is voicing what they haven't been
able to say for a while now
but then also i think it goes back to
them not being able to successfully
get a woman
so
it's more along the lines of they can't
get it like there are a lot of in sales
yeah
is that is that is that what's going on
is there a lot of guys that just can't
get girls i mean i would say like
there's a lot of insults pretending to
be red pill men
and that's like causing like people to
like mistake like in cells forever men
like some people are just angry at
females because
they're just angry at females and some
people aren't angry at females and just
want to be better
so you so you don't think like
so you haven't seen a rise in men being
angry at women
i mean like i know people who are angry
at females but it's like i don't know a
lot of them
like i can name a few and i can tell you
some of the stuff they've done
but
do you have red pool rage
[Laughter]
that's a big one
i wouldn't say i think the word the
wording is wrong i wouldn't say it's
rage
i would say it's
red pill
adapting
what does that mean
it means
like okay
i'm not i'm not hamza from sam's chicken
do you know what i mean i could get a
girl if i want to get a girl do you know
what i mean what does that mean
when i say that i mean like the
invisible man i'm not the invisible man
then there's a bunch of invisible men
that walk around london right now that
women would not even stop and give like
10 seconds of the day to night the
invisible man i'm not one of the
invisible men but i know invisible men
that's what i mean why do you think
you're not an invisible man
um
all right it comes down to this
when i'm when i'm approaching a girl to
to like
talk to her and stuff i do get the
f off or
leave me alone or the friends say leave
my friend alone i get that and me
because i'm like i know well enough i'm
not gonna let that stop me from
stopping the next girl
but that in itself might stop a man from
speaking to another girl so you you in
effect by turning him to f off is
stopping him from finding another girl
because you are not going to go up to
the guy and
check him out are you
or you make yourself available
what is in a woman wouldn't approach a
man
in general
like it it does happen but i mean in
general like it's she would more make
herself available like she'll go next to
him or she'll brush past him or she
would say hi have you got the time or
like do you know like she would never
just go like you i like you come what's
your number do you know me that's more
i mean
i think like going on kind of from like
the independent and feminism like sorry
the independent and like feminism
movement
i think more women now do
approach men i know a lot i know a lot
of my friends wouldn't think twice about
like if that's someone they like not
even a man like does anyone if there's a
person they're interested in
you have you don't need to be the
indirect like shove the shoulder or oh
what's the time like you'll just be like
you don't think like recently men are
like less likely to come up to you and
speak to you oh no they still do but i'm
saying if a woman's interested she'll
come to you
you said
you were shaking your head
but when he was talking about that yeah
yeah i mean i feel like guys would still
come up to you regardless even if they
get turned down no that's men with
confidence yeah yeah but how many men
are there with confidence are you a guy
with a confidence stuff
i mean like it's not only just
confidence like it's kind of like
courage it's not it's not only that it's
kind of like tied together yeah
it's like what do i look like as a guy
going up to a woman in the street like
i'm not saying this is me but like i
know some people think of it like this
like they don't want to go up to a woman
and then potentially be seen as a
predator
you gotta remember your eight your age
though you're like 18 you most of your
relationships are started online
i i don't instagram i don't believe in
online day and like majority of girls i
meet i meet in person
okay
so i know i mean you said you don't go
up to girls but i didn't
so do you would you understand because
you were talking about feminism earlier
yeah like do you understand why men
would have formed like a movement like
mocktail
of course does it does it makes sense
because of because of the feminist 100
i've given you i've okay i've got seven
apples and a girl's got seven apples
i mean sorry seven mangoes
yeah
when women's talk about first of all
like i'm a black man from london do you
know what i mean so when i when i hear
certain white people come to me and talk
about like the patriarchy i'm like i
don't know what that's about because you
know i mean i was
my family's been slaves like so i was
less than we wasn't even in the house it
was outside of the house so we couldn't
have proper relationships like black
people black women are the highest
um percentage of people that get
divorced
so we've got a obvious problem in the
black community
but i say all that to say i have seven
apples and she has seven mangoes she has
she could take the kids if we divorce
she she she gets um alimony she gets
like um there's certain concessions for
women
that back in the day they had and a man
had which was like i don't think a lot
of men actually want to force to go out
and
and have to look after their family it's
something that's inside of them that
they're like you know i mean you just
i don't know it's like breathing if you
just know that you have to get up and do
like being uh
would you call it a protector and a
provider provider yeah so
i think that juventus makes men angry
now because i ha
like you've taken my role away
i've give i've given you i've given you
two mangles and you haven't given me an
apple yet so right now you're sitting
down with seven apples and two mangoes
but you haven't
you still you still get the kids if you
leave in this independent relationship
you still get half of the money in
alimony in this independent relationship
you still get to go outside wearing what
you want and be on instagram in this
independent relationship
you know i mean there's just a list of
lists of stuff that women are allowed to
do continuously and there's no like
give and take do you know what i mean so
that's why i think relationships work if
i'm not gonna if i'm if i'm giving you
i'll be like okay
have this have this i'm not gonna just
be in a relationship and i don't need to
be in a relationship
and that's me i'm not mixed out i don't
go my own way i'm i'm more red poor i
know what ladies are about so i've
adjusted to it and that's how i proceed
i am i'm completely comfortable with how
i am
with no girlfriend you ladies like you
had some disagreements over there boy
please tell me like i don't i don't mind
disagreements
you can go oh no you go first
you kill him no i'll kill him second
no um
i don't know i i get your points and i i
feel like many people
this day and age look out for themselves
only so i see how it can be um
you you can feel taken and taken
advantage of because a lot of people do
like to take the piss like oh yeah i'm
going to take half of this why do you
need to take half of that like you
didn't earn that you're just being like
evil at that point so i do understand
but so women evil now
some people i feel like men and women
are both evil i don't think it's
inherently a female or male trait it's
just
up to that person what what security
have you got for women that choose not
to be independent women though so
some women have the choice now to be
independent or to be traditional if i
want to be a traditional woman why
should if i leave my husband i'm not
entitled to half of his money if i've
helped put towards i have kids i have a
house to look after you can't just leave
a woman like that that's how that's why
relationships were the way it was
do you get it
you if you give a man your body before
you give him a ring he has no obligation
to
marry you
but like you've already given it to me
like that's what you have to me to me
to bargain with you've given away your
bargaining chip
but what if she just wanted that too
yeah but you can't expect a man to sit
down to stand on one knee if he knows
five people that you slept with do you
get like i don't know i understand i
understand that but as in like why does
it have to be
i don't know
ah there's something why does it have to
be like men that's the person that that
happens to you
yeah i don't i don't i really see things
from such a neutral perspective i'm
going to say it from like i i identify
as pansexual so i i
date or open to like all gender yeah so
i don't just believe in man and woman i
believe in non-binary if you go back
into history there were five genders
yeah of like femme femme femme mask in
female mask fem in male and mass
masculine and then hermaphrodite
in
let me get let me go there but those are
the five genders and how like people can
approach there's different energies that
people carry and different have if you
want a traditional wife
and you're a traditional man then that
is for you but if someone wants to be
more independent then that is for them i
feel like everyone has different
energies and bring different things
you're missing my point it's not that
you're not allowed to be independent
it's that if you are independent there's
consequences for your actions like you
can't expect the same results if you're
doing something different like like okay
i can't i can't say to you one one
second um
here's my mango cost ten dollars and
then you give it to someone for one
pound and then you want me to come after
and buy it for ten dollars i'm not gonna
do that because you given it for one one
pound
do you understand
what do you guys think i i feel like i
feel like
oh i said i feel that and not feel like
what you feel like
okay like if all women in london sat
down or in the world tomorrow woke up
and said you know what
we are not going to have sex with men
unless they marry us what do you think
men's going to do i mean
i guess i'm going to the store to buy a
ring no no i'm but i'm saying
do you think the marriage rates will go
up or do you think it will go down um
but would it be equality though would it
be quality marriages or would you just
be trying to put a ring on what's the
quality of equality marriage for me is
that a man is held to a standard by god
by a judge by her family my family our
friends
by
um
everyone that see us that nowhere
together in a union if we're just
linking like it doesn't matter if you
see me with three other girls down the
road but if i'm in marriage now i have
kind of more of like
more to lose yeah so you have to give
the man more to lose in order for him to
be more faithful
because i mean
and if you were cheating or not
okay right
it's weird because i i'm i think i'm the
person that decides whether or not we go
and be in a relationship or not
i would agree in saying that it's
normally a man it was a it's a man's
lead if a relationship goes that way
with a female on i would agree with that
yeah right so in a sense and you are for
sex in terms of like um
access
what do you mean in terms of
i mean
i get what you mean so he means like
men so women control access to sex right
okay men control access to relationships
yeah yeah okay so if you take away your
bargaining chip from us but like for you
then we don't need to marry you we could
just have sex with you until we're 80.
like you know i mean i i could go on
uber and get food i could
get someone to come and clean my house
i could have casual um sex with with
women that want to have casual sex
because they want to be independent so i
mean like why do i need to sit down now
and give a ring and risk
half of my
wealth or like my kids taken away or why
would i risk that why would i even get
married to you but why are you getting
married only like for sex like because
with sex my love it's not just for
pleasure it's for having kids so if you
want the next generation of kids to come
yeah you want them structurally coming
under a two-parent household whereas the
mom and the dad
and or
sorry or like a woman and a woman or a
man and a man sorry guys
but it's under marriage where it's under
law and like so there is
marriage is hundreds of years old like
we didn't just crack the code of
marriage the other day like we know we
know what the benefits of marriage are
so
like
okay
you would look you would be looked upon
badly in back in the days if you left
the marriage right yeah you would do you
know what i mean yeah you would so it's
like
we don't even take marriage for the same
like
so just let me just go back to um
something that somebody said earlier i
can't i can't remember who it was
someone said that there's a lot of men
that are not getting
women
right so like you have the you you said
the 90 right it's a 1910 rule right so
if you got the 90 10 rule 90 of the men
sorry 9 of women
i would say eighty but eighty percent of
women want twenty percent of the men
yeah in the world which is why women are
always fighting over men
so
because there's a there's a huge chunk
of men that women are missing
like he said the invisible men the
invisible man there are men out there
that women don't even
they don't even look at however the
average man which which is what he is
yeah doesn't get any play his dm's are
dry yeah he
he's probably socially a little bit
socially awkward he doesn't really know
how to talk to women whereas women as
you know you guys can walk out of your
houses in your jogging bottoms with a
bonnet on and still get male attention
right men average men don't don't get
that right the average woman can
actually do that right so
would you say that that is making a lot
of those average men angry
definitely i feel like they're not just
angry they're kind of like
they're kind of seeing it as like
there's nothing really there for them
anymore so that's that's going to lead
to them having to move away like you
brought up earlier men moving away
because most men are not well i think
half of the population of men probably
over do not have any children
they don't have children whereas you
know the men that are actually breeding
with women
are breeding more than one woman
generally if you ask a man if he's got
more than one baby mother yeah so the
women are now choosing
the guy there's something about that guy
no matter if he's got two three four
baby mothers there's something about him
that other women always choose to breed
with him and there's a whole subsection
of men in this world now who are looking
at all of that and they're thinking
when's my turn yeah that's women
cheating
say again that's women cheating
so they're cheating the game so
as i said a man is decision to for the
relationships so a lot what a lot of
women do is they force the relationship
upon the man
you have no control whether or not a
woman has if you disagree or disagree go
for it
actually i'm just processing and
listening okay okay go ahead don't
process you go yeah
i was gonna say for my point earlier
about um
marriage obviously you know it's better
to
raise a kid with more people you know it
takes a village as they say yeah um and
it really does like even if you just
have two parents like
you need more than the two parents to
really raise a kid but my point is is
like you shouldn't be getting married
only for sex
like i wouldn't want to be married just
because like oh i'm good like it's not
just oh okay it's hard for me to just to
understand to you um
for me to explain to you what sex means
to men it's different to women like you
wouldn't you would never understand what
sex means to a man you just wouldn't yes
it's not just the sex
because it's exclusive sex as well it's
um what kind of sex as well is
how how she like i don't think any man
just
marries a woman just for sex
but i would say that sex is highly up up
there and one of the things that he's
looking for
so i think i think i think the statistic
out there that says the less men have
sex or society has sexless men sometimes
the more aggressive that society can
become because men are not
expelling and expressing that sounds
accurate right so
um there was a guy last year called jake
davidson i don't know if you heard of
him he's a guy who
is in plymouth he went on a rampage
right killed people did you hear about
that my hometown oh really oh so you are
about to literally i don't read it right
okay but
when you look at his like last videos
that he made
he turned he went from red pill like i
said that whole red pill thing and he
just went
he was in a rage because he was so upset
he didn't get any play from women he
didn't have any sex his life was boring
and he just said you know what
i'ma let the world know and he took it
he took a gun and he killed like five
people
in the town were they like all women or
was it like
um i think a man got i definitely think
a man got killed but i think it was his
parent was his parents
a child a dog and the dad that was with
the child i believe right was it murder
suicide or just like yeah then he killed
himself afterwards
oh my goodness but that's crazy though
but my only thing is
why is it a woman's problem because also
like in the 80 20 thing um sure
women are more sought after in that
sense no no no
no
the 20 man is more so after
beautiful women are everywhere you don't
find a six foot seven foot
tall guy that makes a lot of money that
knows how to talk to women that's the
best sex you've ever had in your life
these guys don't just walk around like
everywhere like you know what i mean
it's more it's more it's rarer to find
that kind of guy so that's why it
happens because you might not move to
that guy but there's another pretty girl
that would move to that guy and then
while he's
trying to sort out his issues with her
there's another girl that's moving to
him and then there's another one and
then he goes out to the club and there's
another four and then he's like oh i
forgot about
kyriana i forgot about letitia there's
another two coming then there's another
freed and it's like well i'm just
getting so much casual sex so much
casuals i could turn on the tap or turn
it off whenever i want
and it's
it hurts girls when when it's that
position because they don't like to
chase uh girls hate to chase men but
girls understand women understand that
um there's competition out there of
course which is why women are constantly
doing their hair doing their makeup
doing whatever
that's for us all the time can you say
that no it really is you say that it's
for you no genuinely so it's it's from
my core it's for me
so it's not to attract a mate no no i
feel like for some people that's because
some people generally they do want to
breathe but my my i didn't even get my
point like my point was to say that
women are everywhere and how guys say
like guys will go after women
and so women are getting more attention
in that sense and it's like this eighty
percent of men that are not getting
anything a lot of women don't want the
attention that they're getting that's
that's the only point i was bringing up
what do you mean i felt when you mean
women get unwanted attention
lots of times yeah i mean you don't want
it until you okay but what happens when
you don't get any attention exactly you
don't you don't want it until you don't
get it
because i've seen tick-tock videos all
over the tick tock of women saying oh my
god like i dressed up today little no
guys
they're not even hollering at me when
women doc because i believe that women
attention is something that drives a lot
of women if women get no attention from
no men
they're not happy
honestly so for me this is just purely
me when i dress up and i'm getting ready
i would rather a compliment from like a
13 year old little girl on the street
thinking my outfit's sick then a man
coming up to me trying to trust me no
but it's not necessarily chirping but
acknowledging the fact that you look
good no but i get his point like even if
you don't like
fancy the guy even if it's like
you would rather
in your head you don't want that until
you don't have that but i'm i'm saying
like i just i wouldn't care at that
point just don't talk to me i feel like
maybe like originally like it was for
like men but then because it became so
inbuilt into society like girls getting
their hair done and stuff like it just
became something that you might have
seen like for yourself
but then
with like
men like we still see it like the same
thing like maybe you don't see it that
way but we do
i think it goes back to traditionally
like you're meant to leave the house
looking nice like i don't care how i
look all the time but um traditionally
like you're meant to leave the house as
your best self um because when you don't
know who you're going to see like
whether it's for work or for
um
yeah but
do you think you should be allowed to to
turn it off and on whenever you feel
like
so in the sense of what do you wear and
do when you want to attract a mate
don't you don't you just say the same
thing also like if it if like you said
like maybe someone from work like do you
want someone from work to see you like
in beauty shorts
and a crop top
well i'm saying like
in the sense of
how traditionally how people are meant
to leave the house is in that theory you
don't know who you're going to see i
personally i don't care like i walk
around with shorts all the time like
that's that's what i'm comfortable doing
that's what i like wearing i mean i
could walk around in a thongs and and no
t-shirt but hang on with what you're
really hoping
you'll be arrested
and a vest like i mean i mean i could do
this
i mean
look but look dave i remember those are
dave chappelle's dave chappelle said
men don't buy nice cars because they
nightlife because they like nice cars
they buy nice cars because they know
women like nice cars they like nice cars
and so they know that that's going to be
the trap quote-unquote to get a woman if
a woman sees that a man's got money
yeah nine times out of ten she's gonna
go for that man now women now you're
saying
women understand that men are attracted
to attractive women but when you walk
out your house or when you do that it's
not to attract a mate yeah
and not only not all the time
because i i walk around half the time
looking like a bum okay like i'm not
trying to attract it but you used to
attract attention
i think this year at least eighty
percent of men before he comes to talk
to sorry guys guys one at a time go on
say what are you saying i was going to
say before before man
you were saying something go on yeah
i'll just say like partially
it would be speaking to the mic please
partially it would be because of that
because of um attracting me to be honest
like up to an accident like it might not
be the complete reason but up to the
next day yeah
you know looking good it just it just
makes life progress a little better
especially
can i just say like does every not
obviously everyone but when people leave
the house what i don't get the goal with
trying to find a mate when i leave the
house i'm not thinking of
yeah because you have a lot of options i
mean but it's not even that like people
go through different stages and you have
a lot of options but there's times in
life where like you don't wanna you
don't wanna be with anyone like there's
times when i've been openly celibate and
i'm out made myself look nice i'm not
trying to find someone i'm just trying
to do me and feel good about myself like
i that was my healing process like
trying to feel good about me and looking
good and finding how
i present myself it's nothing to do with
anyone else yeah it's nice when i get a
compliment but i don't expect that from
a man if it comes from here's my point
what you think is beautiful and sexy is
exactly what a man thinks is beautiful
and sexy yeah
the reason why you
you're even wearing it is because at a
stage in time someone thought when i'm
gonna make this a man would love to see
a woman wear this is my point like in
the sense of if you if you walked out
with a hijab one or you walked out with
a wedding ring on i guarantee you the
amount of men that come up to you would
decrease by 90 percent
yeah if you just have to wait
i hear what you're saying
or you have to hit jab on i almost got
it for now i think i look sexy now i'm
in a men's xl t-shirt yeah and baggy
trousers i think i look flat i don't
care if a guy thinks i look sexy in this
one i think i look fly you look pretty
cool i'm not trying to but i'm not
trying to look i'm not it's not for
anyone no but understand the difference
you look you look pretty if you had a
short skirt on you would look sexy
do you understand the difference so you
don't look sexy you can look pretty
sorry so if you know
but i don't expect you to your
attractiveness when you're like short
okay
i just i disagree on some points like
obviously
certain clothing
makes people attracted to you in
different ways but i i don't agree with
the fact that oh like oh every time a
woman leaves her house she's trying to
attract someone no no i don't think that
i'm saying she can't not expect that to
happen when she's walking out of her
house wearing something that attract
that a man's attracted to what are we
meant to wear like a sack
i feel like they're gonna look either
way or try and talk to us if you have a
wedding ring on then that should be
appropriate
yeah cause like it's not it's not hard
if you see yourself getting married a
lady would like a wedding ring on
you're not gonna like disrespect next
man by going up to his goal you'd be
supposed to try it
right you would be really sick you do
but it's not as like you would you'll
get rid of 90 of men yeah yeah wait guys
have you never heard like when people go
to a bar like ladies will come in with a
wedding ring on
purely just to stop
most men from coming to them i mean like
i can't i've done it if they're in the
bar they're in the bar like
if they're in the bar they're in the bar
like
if you're in the bar yet
it's true if you're in the bar you're in
the bar like you're kind of kind of free
you're kind of free game yeah yeah how
did it work out for you when you did it
i mean i feel like it was about the same
like as far as guys coming up to me but
it wasn't like an amazing amount of
numbers or it wasn't like
one person so it was about the same
okay um swishing gears guys yeah have
you guys seen the johnny depp case
yeah that's it that's an amber head
super chat oh yeah before we get today
actually yeah super chats are gonna get
on us um
let's get to the super chats guys and
see what the see what the audience are
saying about all of you isn't in here
let's have a look
let's have a look i hope they said i
have nice hair or something like
all right let's go to here now
is this it here
yeah it should be on docks
hang on one second
i don't
have it
i don't have it
trying to refresh yeah
like but you see what i mean meant by
before though like in back in the days
if you looked at all picture like video
of england in 19 i don't know 20s yeah
every single woman had on like okay
close i got it sorry one second
um
no i mean hang on one second one second
um
mgtow by logic okay
why is marriage only about sex
what are the ladies actually proposing
men be with women we aren't attracted to
so men are not allowed to have wants and
standards wow have fun with your cats
okay boss said shout out to sarah the
legend thank you very much my brother
thank you very much uh mgtow logic says
again a woman's wants are irrelevant
what matters is what a man is is what
sorry is what man does she value that
she can attract and earn his commitment
just because you want it that means
nothing i want to be nine foot tall so
what
[Laughter]
tim the roof says to the woman on the
right side of the female with oh that's
the old one
is that is that it then
okay
so a woman's wants are irrelevant
i don't know about that i mean i don't
know about that
like so many guys be out there in the
world making sure women have everything
they want but who like how many girls
are going out of their way to make sure
a guy has everything they want wait what
does he mean by a woman's wants are
irrelevant i think the top ten percent
the woman's wants are irrelevant because
that top ten man has options right and
therefore
um if she wants certain things and
certain things for example um he can
just go to the next scale that is just
as beautiful will do exactly what she's
doing for him
and
at that moment her wants are irrelevant
i understand that
i'm so so are you saying to the top 10
men you can see why because having so
many options where your wants as a woman
would be irrelevant i don't agree with
it oh yeah i understand it okay okay i
understand that yeah because you want
him more than he wants you anyway
but i mean average man's wants is
irrelevant to you
no i didn't say that no i'm telling you
it is
why would you say that because she
wouldn't she wouldn't even see the
average man her average man is an above
average man
are you talking about average men yes
okay like average men's what because
okay if you're talking about right so
the guys that has everything or let's
say
you get what you've got yeah like that
sort of the average guys once doesn't
matter to women it's never mad like i
don't care if he wants me
you ain't having me i've got i've got my
man like what i'm saying like you do not
care about what i want like i agree but
i also think women do this thing of like
seeing potential as well
i want to do the whole i can fix him and
like build him up and him
do you think do you think i'm sorry how
do you see potential when someone's like
you've never spotty like you just see
them one day and then you start like
you say hello laying on one of them and
i'm just saying that you just see the
potential right there so you've never
been there you've never you've never
been at that potential state
yeah i think every woman at some point i
think i think it's a lie to say you
haven't like i i can't i don't know you
personally like i just met you but i
think it's a lie like women do see
potential say you meet someone you talk
to them for 15 minutes oh
you know you you can get a vibe off of
someone oh oh i think they can do like
this or it doesn't matter what you think
if they're not actually hit if they're
not actually doing that i mean so like
so you think this is enough
it doesn't mean that i fell for the game
but i'm just saying that women do fall
for potential yeah eight times out of
ten women are going for potential even
if like the guy is worthwhile he can
treat me like crap because i know he
doesn't mean it or i know he's going to
do better someday it's always like
someday or the next thing yeah women i'm
telling you women see potential in
things
so you always say i was gonna say like
you know some men will literally just
like tell you what you want to hear so
like the potential you're seeing is just
a facade so like how are you seeing
potential when he's most likely acting
like
because i know i do it
perfect like not too long ago
i'd take it to the stream
and buy her a chair i'm not doing that
not only that would you go for the man
with potential when the other guy that's
that's that's already there is chasing
you as well
i think it goes along the lines of
attraction so like
no you're you're a misunderstanding
and i think the best way i can explain
is say if i'm with someone and i'm more
attracted to him than the guy that was
chasing after me and i'm attracted to
him or we like vibe on some kind of
level and he's not he's not up to par
and it's like oh i'll keep going for
this because at some point he's not
going to do like this at some point he's
going to be better that's what i meant
when i said that i mean like
i mean like what do you mean he's not up
to par
i was about to piggyback off that
because what do like do you think that
women nowadays have a list that of for a
man that is kind of unrealistic
unrealistic
i think for most people yeah but it goes
back to the social media like oh
this guy has to buy me a birkin but you
can't buy yourself a birkin like
yeah
no but don't like as a woman don't i
haven't haven't you thought that
so i don't you're a woman you're a woman
i don't know what your list is but have
you heard
some of your girlfriend say certain
things and you're thinking like really
yeah do you sell them off
or do you just let it slide like you one
of your friends says like oh
she's got this guy he wants to buy her
barking
don't say that because who who who is
buying anyone
that buy burpees or getting perkins i'm
just saying
because i mean in terms of spending
money on them yeah like
and that's what i think i think um
i think social media is messed up i
think social media has messed up um
people's um like ideas of what a
relationship is do you know what i mean
and i think a lot of the time um when it
comes to like the way the red pill
raised away the way men are angry
nowadays is because social media and a
lot of women have bought into
um some kind of high fancy life when
they don't live that high fancy death
like i said women can women can be on a
boat in dubai and this is what was i was
talking about how when women are pretty
you can have no job and being on a boat
in dubai
just cause your looks
women can do that men can't do that
right if a man's got no job he's not on
a boat in dubai he's not going anywhere
he's just not going anywhere and i think
um
i think those double standards for me is
a lot of the reason why a lot of men
are quite angry
okay
i think men in general could take double
standards i think it's the lack of
appreciation for me taking the double
standards like it's like you expect me
to do it like it's like
like a thank you would help solve a lot
of men's issues if if women said thank
you to men i appreciate you big man you
know what i'm saying i appreciate it
that alone i have i haven't heard for
the last five years
women do you think men are not
appreciated
i mean they appreciate about no no i'm
awesome women okay i i think they could
be appreciated more
so then that's a no then men are not
appreciated i don't think they're
unappreciated but i think say in terms
of society
and i know in terms of society like i
would say
ethics um
i say when i say society i mean like job
roles like normally for me i don't know
like but men are normally favored for
things
so i think because men are favored
i don't know women have that little um
about things treat women are angry at
men nowadays
a little yeah because i think
like going back to traditions women were
expected to be a certain way and they
don't want to fit in a box anymore i
think they do want to be themselves and
i think now women are finding that i
like i think you touched on it earlier
like
they're taken away like a man's stance
so like they can provide for themselves
so like like what am i gonna do for you
but i think
then you need to find a different
balance in your relationship
for me
if i'm looking for a partner
i'd want them to be equal to me equal or
yeah of course it'd be nice if they're
like above
but i'd want someone just the same as me
like i don't know what way what do you
mean
so what do you mean
like ambition ambition-wise like the
same goals earning similar money or we
want to do the same thing that you just
need to have like
be on just on the same path like just
do you believe that there's equality
like do you believe believe men and
women are equal no you don't why why not
i think it differs in each aspect as
well like it will be different in the
workplace it'll be different in a
relationship when it comes to sex it's
different in like in all of like and
more there's so many double standards do
you think things are now heavily skewed
in women's direction or men's direction
i'd say women because we fought for it
but it doesn't mean that men are
unimportant like i think men
don't you think that's why men are angry
i could hear that but it's also nice
that i think how women have found their
independence and stuff like the
persona and
like thing that society has put on men
of like having to be strong and a
provider like it's your time to to take
that time for you
and like work on those other things like
you don't have to be a provider or you
don't have to be that yeah that might be
what society has but why can't you
connect to your emotions man that's not
a provider doesn't get much play in the
society
for you to say that like he doesn't get
much play and
um
i i hear i i hear it but i think it's
because when we talk about i'm just so
not that person
like i just don't it's just not really
like so you wouldn't want your man to be
the provider
like it'd be nice yeah but as long as
i've got myself it'd be nice but as long
as i've got myself i don't expect that
from you
like i i so you would be provided in a
relationship
i'm with as long as i can cover me and
you can cover you like nobody
go on but like you're saying like okay
initially the issue starts off with it
would be nice but then you said as long
as you can cover you
and
he can cover him but i think what you
don't realize is a provider somebody
covers both yeah no i know
but i'm like
i'm just saying when you're coming into
a partnership you're both two individual
people you create one bond but you both
have to bring something to it that's all
i'm saying
so
uh women are you okay with being the
provider no i want the mandate provider
i kind of want it to be more even
but then if if women okay so if as a
woman you had a man who was equal to you
providing or you were his provider um
would you respect him the same way
yeah we're people we're humans it's not
about man we're not against each other
guys guys are they going to respect you
the same way do you think hell nah like
maybe things that can slide now that
won't be able to slide how long how long
she's going to respect you for
a day until until infatuation
i mean until infatuation ends and that's
it like she monkey branches to another
person i feel like she'll provide for me
until tyrell from down the street he's
like six foot nine with like
yeah 45k in his bank comes along and
steals it from me i don't know about 45k
but yeah
no i don't i don't think women um
i think
i think a lot of the time that there may
be women
that will be okay with being provider
there are some women that are but i
think generally women want to be
provided for yeah
i think the difference in that is if the
guy isn't going to be the provider and
say this is where the more partnership
relation like obviously a marriage has a
partnership but on the sense of oh we're
going to split everything and not 50 50
but a balance between it so if you're
not like covering it and we're both like
doing the parts then i'm not gonna be
doing all the housework i'm not like
because if the guy is providing then
okay sure that's fine to say oh will you
take care of the house like i'm gonna
provide the house and you take care of
the house but if we're both going in
together i'm not taking care of the
house and you're not taking care of the
house like if we're both providing for
the house we're both taking care of the
house and i think that's the big
difference okay so this is out my mom
always said it to me yeah like in terms
of this
well not to me but to my sisters
you're gonna clean your house anyway
even if i wasn't there you're gonna cook
food for yourself anyway
so all you need to do now is just put
one extra
cup of rice in there so what were you
going to do if you're by yourself in
terms of uber
you're not going to cook
i would uber
i'll cook for myself once in a while and
then by uber the rest or go out and eat
well then guess what i will i will clean
half the time and you can uber that [ __ ]
other time because yeah but then you're
going to be in a dirty house no you're
good you will be there too
like it's not just one person yeah yeah
it's very
obtuse and like
rude to say oh yeah i'm you should just
be doing this if you're providing then
it makes sense to say okay this is your
part like we're we're paying we're
playing equal parts even though
one is costing more and one why don't we
with mon like money and won't be with
time but
in that sense you're working together if
we're both splitting it no i'm not doing
your chores for you like we're both
going to split because the same way
you're saying you would do this by
yourself
so okay i said this i said this earlier
but i'm going to say it again if the
burglar comes in the house are we going
to share the responsibilities
no that's on you bro it's on me right
you're going to hide behind me right how
often is someone yeah that's not the
point
you know what i mean there's
responsibilities that i have to take on
whether or not i like it or not
i mean am i lying
you name them you would you
okay like you said protector and
provider means protector so if you have
a home together or you have children or
you have a business he's as a man
supposed to protect that i think women
expect men to protect
and if a man doesn't protect for
instance the burglar you don't see him
the same you're you're going to see that
man is weak you're going to you're going
to probably want to go for somebody who
is more of a protector
yeah and like but which is to be
expected like i'm not saying that i'm
not going to
i'm not going to do it but i'm just
saying like again you've taken
it for granted like
i'm risking my life to save you like my
life
like you you can clean up are you not
saving yourself as well
no not necessarily because i could jump
out the window and leave you there do
you know what i mean
i could run faster than you i could jump
higher than you i'd i'm trust me if if
it's between me and you you'll be the
one that's getting hurt if i wanted to
i think it's also important to
understand in a relationship or a
healthy relationship
um
what men and women have is like two
different roles and men a woman's role
would be to be submissive but only if
the man is willing to die for her
so
people get that kind of misconstrued and
when like a man's demanding a woman to
be submissive
the question is really like if
ever you were in a situation
where you had to put your life at risk
for her would you do it and it's at that
moment you can really kind of do about
you you've got it's it's men that you
have to remember i said again men is the
one that decides on the relationship now
do you want a relationship now where
your woman pays half and now when you
come back from work you both got to
clean you both go
you both got golden instruments gotta do
this no you you dedicate which person
does which which person does which do
you got do you women but do do you women
believe in gender roles
like rose for the man and rose for the
woman i think it's only gonna work if in
that in that instance where the man is
actually providing
and
then i will i don't i wouldn't mind if
the guy is doing his part but if we're
splitting why would i be taking the load
of everything so i'm doing the same
things that you're doing plus more
and more
no no
it's going to go wrong i think you guys
are missing the point where i'm saying
if the person is not
doing if the guy is not providing
if the guy's not providing
why am i going to do the extra mile oh
no no no no no no
i am 100 for
for the woman or whoever like if if i'm
gonna take the lesser half or you know
you're going to hide
if if the guy is providing that is more
that is more because money it's not
trust me it's not like in the sense of
this as marriage goes right now marriage
is the perfect combination
is equal right it takes balance so my
thing is if you're
if your money
because you're both going to pay at the
end of the day one is paying in money
and one is paying in time in that sense
because the roles that the women are
doing
you're not getting money for it but
it has to be done like you're paying in
your time so my thing is we both have to
be paying equally in that sense like who
is the balance who were the highest um
consumer spenders
women right so that means you do have
you do get paid for it like a man is not
gonna come back from work yeah
um
while his woman is in his house and not
look after his woman that doesn't sound
like that a traditional relationship
that's not our traditional relationship
yeah but i was having this conversation
the other day i was saying this this
generation
are not marriage material
yeah they're not i really feel both the
men and the women they're not marriage
materials so people are talking about
people are talking about relation
they're talking about marriage nowadays
and i'm like you guys are joking with
yourselves because you guys know that
you ain't marriage material and the
girls know that marriage material so
what's everyone talking about yeah i
feel like nowadays it's kind of like
all right so when you meet a girl
one of the questions that they're going
to ask you is what's your body count and
it's not like
well it's more like between guys as well
i'll ask you that yeah sorry guys yes
she has
sad yeah is that an age thing though
yeah
the reason why we're not like the lower
generations already marriage material is
because we've really seen like a shift
between like what role models are like
nowadays like sex is more like
celebrated but it's like overly
celebrated to where like now everything
is just about sex
like there's no intimacy
and the people that are doing it are
fully involved in full relationships
like beyonce sung single lady she's
married i don't cook i don't clean this
car she's she cooking and cleaning she's
married do you know what i mean it's
like the people the same people that
tell you don't
this
you know i'm saying city girls is the
same one that you know i'm saying she's
got her man
she's sorted she's normally got like
money in her bank account anyway the
person that says that because if she
didn't she wouldn't say that because she
would rely on someone to help her out
like it's like girls that say i'm an
independent lady but you got a man that
takes you shopping you got a man that
buys you bags you got a man that does
this you got amanda you know i'm saying
it sleeps with you when you want you've
got a man that does that's not
independent lady that's like i'm gonna
say that's it's different
yeah and like with that like when we
talk about like independent women in a
relationship
i'm just i'm still gonna be buying her
stuff it's not like i'm gonna be like
i'm gonna come home and be like you got
your own money like go to the store buy
yourself like everything you want
like at the end of the day it's like
even like if you listen to like
something like what they preach they
always talk about some
uh
this where as percy gonna make him do
this that the third but it's never
i'm gonna go to work
get my money up and then go buy a chain
oh you talking about men saying that
like women like they never say like like
when they're telling like what they
i can't
it's kind of like telling the younger
generation
to like use their body
to like control men
but it's not like they're not telling
them to use their body to like go to
work
i get what you're saying yeah
so like it's more an agenda though i
don't feel like that i just think that's
what sells i don't think
i don't know i don't think it's a choice
like music used to be so different do
you know what i mean well you think it's
a music's probably it's a music it's not
a music problem but music heavily
influences the younger generation like
massively so girls scene about twerking
their ass and getting birkins and stuff
of course the younger generation gonna
be like that's what we need to do
so but the thing is but when it comes on
you listen to it
um yeah
we'll be the first shaker house to do
that but i'm saying like there's not
really isn't that a whole contradiction
yeah
isn't that like a whole contradiction no
i'm saying these tell them to not do
what they're talking about no but then
but they're but you're now promoting
what the song's doing by shaking your
ass to it no but also like you have to
think about you can listen to the song
but not do it but if you're listening to
it in a public area you're spreading
that message like now people are
listening to that song like oh so that's
what we need to do let's get on that
i'm so i can land my point i'm just
saying words carry a lot too and if
you're repeating things like wet ass
[ __ ] all the time or twerk twerk or
whatev whatever it is you keep say that
sing that in a club you're thinking that
or then conditioning yourself but it's
come on and you've danced to it right
yeah i mean i'm a dancer so of course
like is it is a different like i
tune a different energy whenever i'm
dancing to anything but again it's it's
not fun
where did the contradiction stop and the
double standards stop like
because we're talking about like
because a lot of men have seen
the kind of contradictions that women go
that women have right and the kind of
double standards that they have and so
i think a lot of the reason why men of
this day and age are angry is because
they're seeing these double standards
they're seeing these contradictions and
they're just expected to just take them
it's like we're just supposed to take it
we're not supposed to question it we're
supposed to take it women can basically
do what they want right and we've just
gotta be like all right fine yeah it's
like paul dance in this female
calisthenics do you know what i mean
like
it's never it's inevitability hold on to
the sport now
you're allowed to be multifaceted like
you're allowed to like for me i can
appreciate or understand a song is
sexual and not and dance to it sexually
but also there's another side of me like
i'm not just that one
twerk in a club like i can then also
listen to [ __ ] gospel on a sunday and
smoking awful and all that there's other
we're multifaceted we're not just one
thing but don't you think women are
generally seen a certain way and
they're not allowed to break that facade
of who they are like because if the
facade of what a woman is is broken then
women get pissed off like for instance i
was the johnny depp and amber heard case
right
so amber had came out saying that john
when she initially came out she said
johnny depp was the abuser and she was
believed instantly right because
women
are obviously
you might want to turn it off bro
the police
yeah because women are instantly seen as
the victim
the enemy team's a victim and so as it
comes out
you you come to find that
she's been lying she's been saying
certain things you know certain things
aren't true like
how is it that women tend in this dance
society in this day and age to be like
i'm a strong independent woman
i am the boss but then you can switch
and instantly be like oh my god i'm just
an innocent little person
i feel like maybe that's because like
they can do that but then they still
have men to fall back to you like
what do you mean like okay so they can
be a strong independent woman but when
that doesn't work out there's always
going to be someone ready
to like give her everything
that user may be so big
um
i don't know can you repeat what you
just said so how is it that women are
women get to be strong yeah and they get
to act like
um they are
just like a man
right women get to stand in men's faces
chatting men's faces shout in men's
faces point point point point point
point point point do all things that we
know that as men are golden aggression
right and then instantly they get to act
like the victim should it not go their
way yeah i don't agree with that so you
don't believe in the amber head case
that's what she done
so no like i agree i agree that's what
she's done like as in like in in general
i don't agree that it's okay for a woman
to be all up in a man's face and then
play victim i don't agree with that but
women get to do it
yeah but i'm not saying i agree i agree
with it
it happens yeah but
the thing is right i think
i listen i watch i prefer to watch
actions and listen to words right so
women will say i've never been i've
never i've never approached a woman or
i've never spoken to a woman and she
said yeah i agree with what that woman
done women always say they disagree with
what the woman done but there's so many
women doing it my question is now are
those women being checked by other women
because when a man checks her then it's
oh my god he's a misogynist yeah well i
hope our friends check her like
genuinely yeah your p like if you have
people if i saw my friend being abusive
or controlling or manipulative to their
partner
i would say something i've been in a
militia of an abusive relationship
before sadly multiple times so i i know
that for someone else to then do that to
someone else nah
if that's your friend you check them
that's not okay
women are women okay with being checked
by other women i don't think they are
but i think right right exactly
the way you do it i think what you are
saying is true because if if it's
something that you've been through you
wouldn't want to lie about it or hear
about other people lying about it and
like knowing that they're lying about it
because you know like how
how serious that is
so but this is the thing though
like you were saying women don't like to
check other women because women like
other women to lie to them
they like other women too
and if a woman does try to check her
she's thinking like oh she's jealous
she's a hater she don't like me she's
never liked me and so when men come
along and check women then we're the bad
guys like people like kevin samuels for
instance kevin samuels came and he
started checking women i believe the way
women should have been checking women
like they weren't going to have it from
another it's different when a man does
it to you right absolutely
a woman saying something you'll be like
oh yeah like it's your girl you're like
mate you might think yeah they might be
jealous of me or they might be this as
soon as a mouse it will hit you 10 times
harder
and i definitely agree with that yeah
so we're out here doing the job that
women should be doing but you know what
should be doing but it's just received
differently
but in that case does that mean like i
so if i was to tell a woman off
it hits harder when i do it to when a
girl does it because you kind of see
like other women weak like they don't
really like what they say doesn't really
matter to you like you're gonna hear
them say it and then be like i don't
care i i think it's that because i will
check my friends like i have no problem
doing that because you sound crazy
and it's like oh no don't say that i
don't want to hear it or i'm not ready
to grow so i'm like i will be willing
fully ignorant in a sense but it's like
what's the point if you know that like
you're so far away from the truth or
what's right why are you going to keep
doing that oh like no it's fun okay
[Music]
okay so when like for instance when
kevin samuels told women to buy a dog
and die alone did you see that no
no
so
what because and the reason why he said
that
was because there are a lot of women who
were
in his eyes delusional right as to the
expectations of a man
she may be a woman that's got three
different children for three different
guys and now she's asking for prince
charming
right to come in swoop in after she's
made all of those mistakes and she's
like yeah i want like i want my jay-z
now and he's like
buy a dog and die alone because because
basically the the list that you're
asking for is you do not qualify for
right so
i know women
and i'm sure you guys know women that
you know
are batting out of their league asking
for something that they shouldn't be
getting
and they're and they're saying yeah this
is what i want but as a woman you won't
tell her what kevin samuels told her
no i will
yeah yeah i don't have a problem
[Music]
but what like
you tell them about the word listen so
what was the point in you telling them
the point it's the same thing with kevin
samuel's telling them like
whether they listen or not it's not my
problem but kevin samuels is is a very
influential man like if he was to tell
you off like there's records of him
doing that like yeah but you're hearing
the the conversation that doesn't mean
that the people from their from that
conversation enacted the things that he
said to do so you can you can hear all
day if you're not implementing it it
doesn't matter yeah i mean like it's
like it's there like people that you
know locally like will be able to see
that and be like oh okay so these are
problems with her like she's a very
controversial person i'd rather avoid
her i'm not saying that like everything
that kevin samuel said was correct but
he did have like some points like there
are things that needs to be done before
you can get certain things right let's
pause hang on i'm going to read some
super chats first i want to see what
what it orders saying um we got one from
ts
oh sarah is the truth women see
potential is cap they only see chad and
tyrone potential
five
five for eight thirty percent fat fifty
uh 45k has potential for the most part
he'll have to realize that potential
before he gets a fair chance out here
and that's a fifty dollar super 50 super
chat thank you very much to
um
mgtow biologic 9.99 ladies do you give
men free sex
then that then then why should a man
give you a birkin you must cooperate
with people not demand your wants
are granted for free
all right hang on the uk economist 10
pound women say traditional men are no
more but remember that a gentleman would
often be the lady who is not promiscuous
and waits for marriage chivalry will
return when women become traditional
again
jeez
um jc five dollar super chat wow fellas
find you a woman who once likes to clean
the home unconditionally she doesn't
need to do something
for her to keep her house clean
and we have one more super chat by motel
by logic ones are irrelevant means her
wants are one side of reality you can't
buy an apple that doesn't exist your
wants are irrelevant unless matched by
someone else's granting of them
yeah like i i'll get what he means now
infinite possibility what it means now
it means that you want a six foot nine
guy with a hundred thousand do you're
it's irrelevant because you're not gonna
get that yeah because
you're you're overweight your average
you don't look good unless you're
wearing makeup you've slept with the
whole block like i was going i could go
with all the you listen listed bro i
mean like it's like some of these girls
they would want like the best guy but
it's like ah
you're not there yeah and it's like
you're not allowed to tell them they're
not there you're not there like you know
i mean like your your your parents
should have told you that your
friendship told you that i'm telling you
that now you're not there
just just because i sound harsh coming
from a man i i don't think it's harsh
because i get what he's saying yeah same
i mean like the same exactly that woman
won but the thing is this is a thing
though
why did kevin samuels get such backlash
if he's just saying that because that's
all he was saying
yeah that's because he was getting too
passionate into it and they kind of saw
us like this is a man who wants like
they they kind of saw as he was trying
to be destructive to be destructive but
it wasn't like he was trying to like
cause a change but he knew the only way
he would cause a change was to go
extreme with it i don't think kevin
sammy was extreme
i think he was just
realistic
but they said that he had red pill rage
kevin samuel would not be like something
special 10 years ago
um
like
10 15 years ago kevin simon was not
nothing special guys were more rooted in
that they were more upfront than that
they were more like do you know what i
mean they were more
misogynist
in quotes all right so even
i got a question like that so are you
saying that men nowadays
are more feminine oh one hundred percent
yes
let a lady say because ladies like yes
yes all right why are men more feminine
oh you want me to go yeah um i feel like
as time goes on i guess um i feel like
guys have been more able to express
their feelings more so because in the
past you see a guy crying and that was
taboo like
guys don't cry like what are you crying
for like you're supposed to be strong
you're supposed to be a man men don't
cry now you see guys crying now you see
guys more in touch with their feelings
saying
what they want out of relationships to
women or taking on those roles and i
feel like it's been kind of like a shift
like women are becoming more masculine
and
as you see more women being independent
and stuff like that it's like oh they
get labeled as aggressive and other
things and it's like the tables have
turned a little bit and then maybe
that's what's bringing up some of these
guys and being angry because
they're some i feel like some of the
guys that are angry are not
as feminine
i mean but like isn't that what you guys
want by exciting equality because like
equality is to meet in the middle it's
like if if you're becoming more
masculine we're becoming more feminine
we're coming closer to the center like
isn't that what you want like that off
guard they don't want that
one they they think they want that but
that's not actually what they want yeah
like i'll tell you why your your your
friend in the friend zone is feminine
like do you know what i mean you don't
want you you're saying you don't want
your friend's own guy you want the guy
that you you know what i mean you it's
like why is a guy in the friend zone
feminine that's because i don't think
the friend zone exists
it's just a friendship it's this is a
friendship but a man and a woman can't
be friends like that
actually they can't approaches hang away
you were saying why is that a bad thing
that men are becoming more is that what
you're saying um
what would you say i think you said
something about coming together like
close like um men being
more more feminine than women
i think that's like a good thing because
you men didn't want the struggle of not
to struggle even though
it is but
the pressure of providing and protecting
like surely it's a good thing women
women aren't attracted to uh feminine
men who are like i don't know guys one
at a time
women are attracted to feminine men
i am i think if what's wrong what's
wrong with feminine that being in touch
with you generally
generally women are not attracted
they're associated with feminine traits
but it doesn't make a man girly so
you're still a man so that guy so that
like i said that guy that you're
attracted to that feminine man if like
my brother over here was saying um
there's a burglar in the house he's like
oh my god baby go and deal with the bad
guys is that okay with you but you're
like that's that's definitely a
stereotype
is that a feminine man or what if he
what if he made you fight what if he
made you fight instead of him
well if i do karate or mutai or
something maybe it's better i go
but this is uh your music can only go so
far
because strength-wise he's like a
hundred and thirty years
i get your point
i'm just saying that i don't think it's
a bad thing that men are becoming more
feminine and women are becoming more
masculine it just makes you more human
we have both energies running through
your your
your masculine and feminine in one
here's what i've got to say about that
what makes me mass masculine is what
you're attracted to and what you're like
okay okay
me being masculine is me
you know if you get what i'm trying to
say if i'm if i'm being something that
you're not attracted to like or that
you're not then you're not going to like
me but you're masking like you can be
masculine that's fine i'm saying there
are some men that are masculine but they
also are more in touch with their
feminine side there's nothing wrong with
that oh no no there's not there's
nothing wrong with that yeah we're not
talking about it but what what about
feminine men yeah we're talking about
feminine men in terms of should all men
be like more feminine like i i think
that if you're if you're a feminist
how do you define a feminine man
well it's kind of like okay
like meaning
he cares more about his parents than you
um
he spends more time in the bathroom he's
got all of these nice oils he likes to
give himself a camera very emotional a
little very easy he's over emotional
yeah um
um he's he's rude but as a matter of
fact ruled by his emotions yes um women
don't like men like this okay women like
men to be to know what they want to do
to get it done
and they can talk about it afterwards so
to me
like looking at love island all of those
men are exactly like that yeah like and
i was saying have men become more
feminine nowadays like i think they're
exactly like that yeah so yeah so
brazilians what do you mean
yeah they go and get there they go get
wetlands and stuff like that
and stuff like what like that's not a
room that's not man that's not man
when you say feminine you mean about
appearance not about emotionally and
apparently everything the lack of
testosterone in their bodies
i'm talking about um how they speak how
they're around women how they're around
other men
feminine men like
broke like no backbone bro like
you you you're very agreeable you don't
like um tension you don't like
confrontation
a lot of traits that men have make them
where they are do you know what i mean
it's like i'm a boss because i am not
easily agreeable yeah and also like i'm
a boss because i i i'm i'm like stern
that that necessarily is an alpha like
you see a feminine man is just not an
alpha man and that is people women just
want alpha men i'll be rude
that percentage of men that women are
looking for are alpha men what what
people what classes are for me
um
sorry go on yeah but i feel like alpha
men and things like nature do not exist
because like if you're trying to be an
alpha
you're forcing yourself to do it like
bro do you know someone in in like your
college or something that gets all the
girls yeah but like no no no you know
someone right you know the guy that you
see and you think
like a next one yeah another gal yeah
yeah you know you see you you know you
know the guy yeah don't pretend like you
don't know who he is or you're ignoring
who he is because i feel like i tried to
be like him or you tried to act like him
or you tried to do his you have his
traits or you no i feel like someone's
trying to like sell a blueprint like
there is people that are naturally like
that but i feel like because we're all
unique and things like nature like no
one can be like one version of an alpha
like but because there's like this
blueprint that's out there like oh if
you're an alpha you have to be providing
you have to be strong you have to be six
foot
you have to be and alpha is strong
because you're a leader like you're
taking the lead yeah but anyone can take
the league it's just do you have the
courage to stand up and say anyone can't
take the lead because if that was the
case everyone would be leaders yeah
exactly but that's only because you let
yourself follow someone else and that's
why you never have an opportunity to be
the leader no you're either alpha or not
like it doesn't matter if someone's
gonna give me that opportunity i'm gonna
take it i'm gonna take it if i'm if i'm
the strong person if i'm the biggest
person i'm going to go for it doesn't
matter if you want me to have it or not
i'm going for it because in that sense i
would be the alpha like alpha is always
going to be the strongest person you
could be strong but you might not be
smart
and that's the issue
okay you're misunderstanding the terms
alpha when i use it like there's a
difference between like the alpha guy or
the high value guy like if you bring
value to a woman
like
it's hard you got like me bringing value
to you is not me being an alpha me
bringing value to my woman is me being
an alpha
women see this like it's like certain
girls they would look at guys that have
kids and see how they treat their kids
and be like oh yeah yeah i mean that
that's an attraction woman like some
women they'll be like okay i see okay
i've seen him in the in the office i've
seen how he is how he controls the room
among other people i like that a man is
not necessarily like that a man is more
like um
look at that
you know what i'm saying she done her
hair that night all right say no more
she's walking i'm not really looking for
her like traits in terms of masculine
traits i'm looking for her feminine
traits so that's what i mean when i say
like
how you being an alpha woman
is you being a lonely woman
because like yeah being a masculine
woman normally leads to loneliness yeah
i mean someone might like them but it's
just yeah but that would be the
exception i i have to agree with what
you're saying like women who find
themselves trying to outdo men in a
masculinity department
seldom find a long-term partner because
men generally want feminine women and a
lot of women nowadays have become quite
masculine
the men become quite feminine
and so
you know like i said that's one of the
reasons why i guess
red pill rage men are kind they're kind
of missing
people like kevin samuels people like
the red pill community gave men
their
masculinity back to some degree because
i felt like i think they felt like they
were losing it
i feel i think men felt like they were
losing their masculinity they were being
told that their masculinity is
misogynistic it was toxic all of this
kind of stuff and so
you know i just i personally think that
a lot of a lot of the red pill community
could calm down a little bit i'm not
going to lie to you i've seen some of
the comments
from and i'm just like all right bro
chill do you know me like yeah
just chill out a little bit but
like i said like if you suppress
something for so long and i think the
reason why we are seeing such a huge um
explosion of these red pill community
type things and magtile community type
things is because when you suppress
something for so long it will explode
like pressure burst pipes as i like to
say pressure does burst pipes and i
think that when um
when one man like kevin samuels was able
to say you know what i'm gonna like it
is all the guys are like oh yes now we
can say it you know what i mean so
um yeah that's another reason why i
think you're seeing kind of an explosion
of like angry men
uh sorry i'll just say my problem with
the red pill though is that every man
you can't all be high value
not every man is a ha you can't work in
mcdonald's and be overweight and talk
about your high value how you want this
kind of girl and no bro like you have to
have men have to have improvement as
well like do you know what i mean i'm
not of the kind of people where it's
like yes girls are wrong girls are bad
girls are bad girls are bad i just
acknowledge your bad
in the midst of me acknowledging our bad
but men we have a way of kind of like
communicating to a man easier like how
he's messing up you mean like if you're
like bro what are you doing with that
thing brother you know that didn't i
don't know what was that like relax
don't be walking out and roll with that
or holding hands and or bro don't do
that don't hit your girl like do you
know what i mean or like
we're more like quick to do and women
and women know this because when
whenever they want something done
they'll be like we need the guys to help
us out so what were you saying
yeah i said um men are generally quick
to check other men when they're doing
the wrong thing yeah 100 yeah i don't
believe in that statement at all
what does that mean what do you mean
like wait i'm sorry can you repeat what
you just said yeah i said men are
generally quick to check
men are generally quick to check their
man like their friend or whatever if
he's doing something wrong in terms of
how he relates to people
what he's doing financially or whatever
she looks like she disagrees maybe
financially but like there's even
campaigns there's literally campaigns
like of
men cut like as we were talking about
earlier like trying to chirp girls in
the street and us feeling unwanted and
man then just sitting there watching
their friends doing it and you can see
the females uncomfortable yeah why don't
you check him then
i'll tell you why it's not like majority
of times like we do check them but then
people that do it
don't care like we we do our hardest to
check them like i've checked a lot of my
friends as long as you do no no i'll
tell you why because
who he's checking
is not dressed appropriately
he doesn't come correct so you're saying
she deserves it she deserves to be
confronted or have a guy come up to her
when she's alone is late at night
you've got a group of men around a
single woman kind of yes yes you think
it's her bro you think
i'm out of time
[Music]
because
if it was the other way around
that's how it would be for men in a
sense what do you mean in the sense of
this
if men was the one that was
in the position like how how women have
structured it in terms of it's okay for
us to do it but it's not okay for you to
do you think women corner man and you've
already said multiple times during
during this podcast that you've said
that a man is stronger than a woman so
you know you and your friends going
around a single female is gonna
naturally intimidate her but that's okay
because of what she's wearing how many
times have you been hit before by a man
multiple no when you say multiple how
many times because i i can't count i
said i've been in abusive relationships
i've been hit multiple times yeah but
okay but when i say this i mean the
sense of this
i think a man is more has more to be
scared of another man than a woman
should be scared of a man like it's more
likely for a man to to hit another man
than for a man to him no not these days
no and i will tell you that because men
are men are more comfortable going after
women because they know that the woman
cannot fend for themselves exactly so
they're not man enough to go for a man
so they're going to go for a woman
because oh wait what i don't know i see
what they're saying because like we
could targets like that's how they
like they see us weaker targets but now
everyone's just like like back then
there's like mad fights like pb safari
all the time but now it's kind of like
in them circumstances like we've been
like taught to like find another way
around that so like if we see someone
stronger than us we're not really gonna
try to test them anymore okay okay if
you was to walk down the road naked do
you think someone has the right to stop
you and ask
today coming on the dlr here a girl with
wait hold on she was wearing leggings
and i could see every single segment
she's still lagging hold on she was i
could see everything still closed let
him land please
i could see everything like you're not
you're not leaving anything for the
imagination like just because i see is
see-through now is see-through but
because it's a leggings now it's okay
but i've i've seen everything
nah you don't why are you taking it
there like why does your brain instantly
sexually because i have testosterone and
you have estrogen it's like you saying
why do i have to why did you have me
walking down
me walking down the street in a dress
instantly makes because i look feminine
means you can come up to me and make me
feel intimidated because that's
literally wrong i don't think you should
feel intimidated i feel that girls i
should feel empowered no i believe girls
feel intimidated even when men don't
want to intimidate them so i'll give it
to you like this i'm just walking down
the road chirps and you you feel
intimidated you can't tell me that when
the girl when the when the woman walks
across the road because i'm walking
behind her with a handbag and she
crossed the road quickly that's my fault
but it's not weird but you know as a man
you are bigger you are stronger it's
late
let me finish but it's late at night and
you know by you walking close you don't
know what the [ __ ] she's been through
okay and you might make her feel
uncomfortable about walking close to her
so how do you know that guy is not going
to be the guy that saves her so you've
told me to f off now yeah and you've
gone around the corner
wait hold on you've gone around the
corner and an another guy the best way
to stop at one guy sounds kind of
personal bro how about god
it's like if he was in trouble are you
one of them guys that goes up to girls
in the street late at night and chaps is
them speaking to them it depends yeah
depends if she's looking crazy pretty
enough if she's looking
like available enough yeah hand on my
heart i beg you
check yourself before you do that
because you have no idea how
uncomfortable or scared or afraid she
doesn't know you remember you you can be
a lovely i know we've had like disagree
i can see you're a nice guy yeah but she
doesn't know you okay she doesn't know
you and you approaching is intimidating
there's a way you can go about i don't
know obviously how you address a woman
but if you're aware of the time setting
she's alone the surroundings if you're
with multiple people there's a way if
you want to charge her to do it politely
without intimidating that's that's so
unfair i'll tell you why because you
guys don't want to do the chirps in so
okay if you did the chirps in
please be guaranteed for 100 women
wouldn't stop men at two o'clock in the
morning four o'clock in the morning two
it doesn't matter what time it will be
for them so if okay so as a man you
gotta remember i i didn't have a choice
whether or not i was born a man or not
okay so it's not the fact that i'm
stopping you in the middle of the night
because if a girl stopped you in the
middle of the night you would stop and
talk to her it's the fact that i'm a man
so now you're being sexist because
you're not basically hold on i'll tell
you why you're being sexist because
you've already decided
what i'm like before you even know me so
it's like okay it's like
you don't see that sexist no i'm saying
that from
you've already said countless times how
men are stronger bigger all of these
things so if it's night time naturally
it's a more vulnerable setting you
you're
i don't agree with what he's saying like
thank you i do get what you're saying
but it's it's unreasonable because
men are biologically stronger like males
males are not men but males are
biologically stronger and if you're
seeing this and back to the original
statement if it's
you're saying no but no i'm not saying
i'm saying that girls don't like a guy
that's shorter than them so the guy
that's cause it doesn't matter if you're
shorter or not it does because no it
doesn't matter if you're shorter or not
you're biologically stronger than you're
missing my point you'll miss my
point i don't know
i get your point
though i didn't even finish though yeah
yeah because he did just ask me so back
to the original how we started this this
sentence right now or this dialogue you
were talking about guys checking your
friends so in this scenario
because you're saying on a one-on-one
thing you're what we're originally
talking about is one uh a woman and a
guy is with his friends and then goes up
to her so checking it in that sense
you're like
it's two different things but it doesn't
matter if a guy is short or tall a male
is still going to be biologically
stronger than a female so yeah okay
what do you think about what he said
i was going back to what he was saying
about checking the guys you say you
check guys but you guys were also
talking about women checking other women
but do you do the checking in public too
or do you do it one-on-one and in public
or both i do both because like because
like okay so if i'm with someone and
they start moving like babookie like
there's a goat there there's like a
crowd of people and he starts acting up
i'm also going to get rid of for his
actions so like at the moment i have to
call it out but it's not like i'm not
caught i'm not calling out just because
it's going to make me seem bad i'm also
calling it out because obviously like i
have sisters and things of that nation i
can't like let that run like i can't be
friends with someone who does that [ __ ]
and then expect like when it happens to
my sister and she's like i'm just gonna
be like okay then
yeah and to be honest that whole um 2
a.m situation any anything that would
make a girl feel really uncomfortable or
you know make her feel unsafe anything
like that would definitely not fly with
me i'll definitely have to check my mind
in that kind of situation and also like
if one of my friends comes up to me he's
like he he saw a girl at 2 a.m
went up to her i'll be like what's wrong
with you because first of all like you
have to understand like a lot is is
there now a a time limit where you can't
allow you're not allowed to check girls
i don't think i'm sorry
this generation is mad it's just like we
associate nighttime activity with like
less protection like people would go off
they do drugs they they so why is she
outside them because maybe
if it's that dangerous why is she
outside she's trying to go home no no if
it's that dangerous why is she outside
what if she just came home from work but
why is she working where she has to
leave and come out in dangerous times
she has no choice
no i'm not saying that i'm saying this
you know fully well it's not dangerous
because okay i tell you why in the sense
of this
[Laughter]
i'll tell you why i agree i'll tell you
why yeah i'll tell you why i tell you
why it's not dangerous because
i'll tell you why
you have you have okay i me as a man
they will never unders you would never
understand because you're a woman you're
allowed to hit a man and not expect
something to come back it's
not yet exactly it's different you could
hit a man
and he wouldn't hit you back in most
circumstances well if he hit you back
and there's another man around he's
going to get hit
that's just standard yeah but if i'm if
i'm if i'm on the road wait did you just
say if if there are two guys around and
the woman hits the man that the other
man is going to hit the other man no
that's not what i said i said gonna
check it
the guy is gonna check the the guy that
hits the woman
no one's gonna check the woman that hits
the man
i have multiple times i've never seen a
man
listen guys there have been um there
have been social studies done on this
that have been filmed and there have
been men and women both in the street
and
the woman has slapped the man and people
be like oh my god it's crazy
but then the man has just been in
norman's face shouting at her and he's
been checked it's been done multiple
times women are more likely to be seen
as a victim
in those situations do you know what i'm
saying and men are more likely to be
seen as aggressive that's the truth but
i then that goes back to everyone
knowing that men or women are females
females are biologically weaker than
that's your facade it's not a facade
it's not
true listen
the trans community will not agree with
you right check this out because
i'll tell you what i'm talking about a
man's weakness is the facade of his
strength
a woman's strength is the facade of her
weakness if she if
if she's acting weak
that's where she gets her strength in
don't act weak around me because you're
not because you said you want equality
you work the same you're strong as us
when it comes to like certain stuff it's
like no we could do it we're girls it's
girl power we could do this but when you
want to and you want to switch off that
little thing it's like oh we're innocent
we don't do nothing oh if you was that
endangered you wouldn't walk at two
o'clock in the morning in london with a
short skirt on and drunk out your head
bopping from side to side london is one
of the safest places in the world right
now what i am saying to you is
you guys are not prepared to go up to
men and chirps them
you do not want a man that's shorter
than you so when a guy that is taller
than you and knows he's your type he's
going to come to you
you've just literally said rape is okay
in that sentence you never said rapes
great absolutely horrendous
great great
great
by you saying a woman can wear what she
wants wiggling our hips down the street
saying she's asking for it hang on wait
wait wait let me let me just let me
listen to what you said that's what that
is that's what you heard hang away wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
guys wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm gonna try and send in this a little
bit right
he's not saying rape is okay one of the
grape is okay
damn it um
so what what it is is that
a lot of the time
women hear things
that men don't say this is what i've
cause i've been sitting here listening
to the conversation
a lot of women hear things that men
don't say
he's not insinuating that that's okay
he never said that it's okay absolutely
not but the fact that you jumped to that
that is a that is a crazy thank you that
is far right on that is on the scale to
say that that's he's not saying that and
the thing is my thing is why
how did you get to that conglomerate how
did you get to him saying yeah firstly
i'll apologize because i'm not messing
with you i'm not trying to even put that
out especially on your neck like of
course
but by you implying that a woman what a
woman wears and how she walks
that is okay then for a man to approach
her that implies that it is okay then
for a man to do what she wants because
he likes to do what she looks like
if he wants to talk to her if he wants
to try get her number if he wants to
make her feel intimidated because he's
trying to get her number like when i
come up to you in the middle of the
night and i say hi miss is that what you
think rape is that
great great is that is that what the
immediate thought is no but i'm thinking
like this
sorry i'm
you coming up to me late at night if i'm
waiting for a cat i've had it happen
before
like you are six foot something you are
so much bigger than me you coming up to
me at this time of night i'm just trying
to get home i'm not trying to interact
with anyone i just want to get home when
do you ever want to interact
you'll know if i want if i if i come up
to you you'll know if i want to interact
with you so the only time you want to
interact is when you come up to me
if i want to interact
with you
remember
earlier on so this so this is the great
area that we men get confusing i think
so it's like if women get no attention
they're not happy
right
but if they get attention at the wrong
time they're not happy
but if they get attention at the right
time they're happy and men a lot of men
generally do not know when that right
time is to give you the attention
they men generally don't know so energy
so but that's the thing if a man as a
man being a um
a hunter let's say right he sees his
quote-unquote prayer and i know these
people don't like these analogies but
i'm just using it as an analogy right
and he says oh that looks nice i'm gonna
go and see what that's saying right
at what time is it okay for him to do
that
because because because what you're
saying is it's not okay after two
o'clock in the morning
no but it's just after two years no but
i'm saying generally it's more
vulnerable
because it meant because what i'm trying
to say is men genuinely yeah go for it
men generally
don't know
you gotta tell them yeah together
viral
bro just wait wait just wait just wait
yeah go on
anywho
right like
like men generally don't know
um
when that time is so like you know when
a woman's feeling you right it's like
she'll make i if she makes eye contact
you said about the brushing past all
those little things that's showing a
sign that she yes it is that she's
interested and you know it is because
she said earlier i mean this in the
sense of this yeah what time is it are
you saying men should be able to
retire well hold on this this will
satisfy him
if it's dark outside you see it's dark
outside and say if if the girl is with a
group of friends then it might be
acceptable but if it's dark outside and
no one is around there's no need to walk
up to someone like sure you they might
be attractive but there's no need like
there will be other women that's not the
only woman in the world that you've ever
found attractive there will probably be
someone else like you said women are
easy to find
beautiful
[Music]
the other 80 do not get beautiful girls
half of them are virgins and the other
half haven't had um sex in a year let me
ask you a question do you see why
do you see why the women are a little
bit
side eye at what you're saying do you
know i know why they are it's because
they're looking at as the guy that's not
their type no i'm not no i'm not it
doesn't matter if you know if you see
that someone is by themselves
like that and that's he just asked what
would be acceptable and we're saying oh
this would be accessible and you're
still saying no no you feel that way the
reason why i say that is because you're
not every girl so some girls might be
like leo's two o'clock i just come from
a club yet of course that's the time to
church no but
the difference i said if they're with
friends okay so if you're when like
you're coming from the club i would
think you would be with friends no
speaking from experience let's finish
most people most girls even girls we
stay together we stay together and you
guys know that oh why are you always
going to the bathroom together we stay
together we're always together so in
that sense yeah that's fine to walk up
to someone because they're in a crowd
but um
if if it's a one person and then even if
it's one person you're saying they're
coming out of the club they're probably
drunk so why are you wanting to like
approach someone that is intoxicated and
vulnerable exactly so you're so you're
when you're drunk you're vulnerable yeah
because you're intoxicated so when you
drive when you're drunk you're
vulnerable you shouldn't drive exactly
so that means that the law sees it as
you're completely able to decide whether
or not as an adult whether you if you
drink and drive you're completely
responsible for yourself
what what if you drink and drive it's
not the man's food that you drunk and
drive so when you when you drink and
walk you should be able to be
responsible as well how can you drink
alcohol and walk down the road that you
so think is the most dangerous place
wherein
what you've what men thinkers
all right hang on let's get some dudes
i'm sure some people may be in the super
chat saying some stuff about this so um
we have lurch 685
499 said ladies always say they like
tall men but is there a such thing as
two tall i'm six eight and often
intimidate women
you've got a thumbs up there bro
um we got marcus
rujo
10
independent from who
you guys agree that woman is independent
from one beta and department of all men
okay we have c anthony johnson five
dollars why is it that women are strong
and independent
mgtow logic 999
he just said grape is okay is the
textbook example of how women derail a
convo when they are losing the argument
another reason why men don't like women
disingenuous and manipulation thank you
that's you sees it like how i see it if
i walk around brixton summer lateness is
that all the supercharger sir
hang on one second
oh we got more
um
oh hang on yeah
uh we got smain tagan
stats show
the main victims of male violence is
vastly men stats show the main victims
of male violence is vastly men this is
legit
common
knowledge
okay
um mocktail logic again
women only control sex because men let
them
men could take it at any time
if we wanted
but we don't you're welcome oh
all right another one hang on wait a
second one second it's main taken
if i walk past a bunch of hood men and
they approach me i might be intimidated
but as long as the intentions are good
then
my fear don't matter can i can i second
second just human 20
dangerous men exist lots of dangerous
men are easily aroused most dangerous
men are out late i don't think anyone is
saying you deserve to be assaulted but
given the factors you have agency in
this situation
jc five dollars ladies you need some
accountability
most men don't grape
you
the most men who grape you know you and
at some point will stop blaming men when
you can control your own environment
is that it then yeah that concludes the
super chats can i rebuttal what that
person just said
go on
this this that's not what i'm trying to
say what my point is if i'm wearing
jewels which i'm allowed to entitle to
fully wear jewels if i want to wear
jewels i'm completely i could there's
nothing stopping me from wearing jewels
i want no woman to tell me to stop me
from wearing jewels but if i walk into
summerley in a state with the jewels on
it's not i'm not saying that
um you deserve to get robbed
like we all know robin is wrong like
getting robbed is wrong but i should not
have been in summer late in a state with
my jewels on hang on a minute are you
now saying that the streets
are that
are not that sticky and detrimental now
some women wait so are you saying now
so you are you now saying that if i walk
into this estate where i know it's crazy
and people get robbed all the time or a
lot of the time i shouldn't wear my
jewels are you now saying that when
women walk the streets you're saying
that women are getting the streets that
dangerous that they shouldn't walk the
way they walk because the streets are
dangerous so they should not be out on
the streets at that time
i think the countries that has the the
least amount of
grape are the countries where the woman
were the most close
um i feel like i'm just saying
[Music]
like the sec what what what does what
what a woman attracted to like what are
you saying like muslim countries and
stuff yeah but then like there's no
certainty
the men in them kind of countries also
like be closer pedophiles and things of
that nature but like what i was thinking
is maybe like
we should as a community of men like we
should hold off on like approaching
women at night until like it kind of
like stabilizes because there's like too
many cases where women go out at night
and then as they're coming home
desperate men like act up because it's
not like that's not my point my point is
all men in dubai they walk around in the
night three o'clock in the morning four
o'clock in the morning five o'clock in
the morning six o'clock in the morning
seven whatever time in the night there's
no difference in the time of night what
i'm simply saying
is this if you want to avoid certain
things happen make certain precautions
and don't just like do you know what i
mean like it can just happen at any time
though like everything
and i've got the reason i will tell you
the reason why that doesn't really make
sense yeah because most people are um
molested and graped by people that they
know within environments that are
comfortable to them so within um
you say dubai
most women that have that done out there
are done it's done it's not done on the
street so they can walk the streets at
night because they know that there's a
very big penalty for doing something
like that it happens within the home
mostly
okay and so so my answer to this would
be this thing
if you're saying that it's mainly people
that you know then why are you scared of
the people on the road then because it
still happens right so so when it's when
it happens is what i'm talking about
because that's what we're talking about
we're not talking about the the people
that are
getting raped from great from people
that they know i'm talking about the
other people
i'm saying if it's just if it's more
statistically likely that the more
revealing like it's like me me walking
driving down the road with a bentley
being six foot tall with jewels on and
expect girls not to look at me bro it's
like what like what attracts men to
women is what you're wearing
but still in running gear like it's not
and he's a police officer which could
take you off guard like you know i mean
like a police officer will catch
everyone off guard
no
like you could be fully closed in the
police office and catch you guys
okay all right sorry you know i actually
think these conversations need to happen
some so men and women can kind of see
where each other are coming from do you
know what i mean and i don't believe
that we're always coming from the same
place clearly i'll be the first
one i don't think we're always coming
from the same place clearly not but um
if we don't have more of these these
kind of conversations then we won't know
where the quote-unquote boundaries are
because i think like i said before um a
lot of men
me personally i feel like i know where
the boundaries are
but i'm saying maybe a lot of young men
don't maybe a lot of socially awkward
men don't they don't know a lot a lot of
a lot of the time you know men gear
themselves up to talk to a woman
they've been waiting to talk to him for
so long because he didn't know how to do
it and now he's got the confidence and
it may happen at the wrong time and
she's like
no i feel weird and he's like
that's the one time so like i said when
women if we're asking women like i said
when is the best time
to give you the attention that we know
women clearly want
maybe you guys need to write a manifesto
letter guys oh yeah let the guys know
write a manifesto
and then we'll know i love how if you if
you said
that you you feel like you know
what can you say to your fellow men um
because me i would say that
i would
myself i'd say that i'm more um
emotionally intelligent and i can kind
of read the room and i kind of kind of
read the energy and read people but i
understand that not men not all men are
like myself
i just i just know that about myself i
know that not a lot of men like i said
when the average guy doesn't even get
any attention so he's he's starved of
attention and sometimes i feel like um
average men that starve their attention
don't know how to express themselves and
they may express it in the wrong way and
i'm not condoning anything right i'm not
gonna do anything but i feel like a lot
of men are starved of attention express
it in the wrong way but i'm just saying
me for me
i feel like
i'm not starved of attention but also
i'm a little bit older do you know what
i'm saying so i've seen a little i've
seen more things so i can kind of hark
back to experience and say you know what
nah that's not the right time do you
know what i mean whereas a lot of guys
are not no but so if if a another guy
were to ask you what would you say not
saying like base oh so based off of your
experience what would the exact answer
be
i would say like i said i'd have to do
it off of my own personal because i i
feel like i can read
energy
from a woman do you know what i'm saying
but that's me personally i feel like i
can do that and i know not a lot of
people can so me personally i don't know
that if it's two o'clock in the morning
and a woman is walking down the street
and i find her attractive
i know that if she's got her headphones
in and she looks at me and gives me a
glance
and continues walking she doesn't want
to know do you know what i mean like she
doesn't want to know whereas if it's two
o'clock in the morning and i'm walking
and she sees me and she
looks at me and continuously looks at me
and is always looking back but in a way
that
i guess you know that she wants you to
come and speak to her then i kind of
know so that's for me but that's my
experience i'm 41 years old do you know
what i mean so i've been on this planet
i've seen a lot of stuff
but a lot of the time men
don't know yeah i was also going to say
something doesn't that come from
practice yeah of course it does it comes
exactly because you have to fail
multiple times to understand a lot of
the time and so where that comes from
practice
you find that most men that are able to
read women emotion with emotional
intelligence would have had practice
they would have done this they would
have tried and tested oh this doesn't
work this does work they've gone back to
their fellow men and gone okay um this
happened to me why do you think that
happened they've had discussions um and
you'll find that that's the only way
you're really gonna
um gain that emotional intelligence to
understand that oh this isn't okay i
can't go this far or i can't speak to
this person but it kind of contradicts
what you're arguing because you're
saying men shouldn't
go out and find this out which is
it's a
it's a taylor two ends you know what i
mean like it's hard because you you're
okay you're doing it because you're
you're a handsome guy do you know what i
mean like that's what that's what i was
saying like just
there's no right time for the wrong guy
to come and approach a woman so you mean
there's no
there's no right time for the wrong guy
to approach a woman
right like they say like i don't come up
but that's what i'm saying because most
a lot of men don't know when to they
just do it when they feel like they're
going to do it
not just that some men some men don't
think some guys don't ever they're never
going to have the opportunity yeah
they're not good enough so it's like
double dutch you have to get in where
you're fitting like you find the
opportunity to go it's like certain guys
don't even chirp sir you know you're not
gonna you're not she's not even gonna
stop and say nothing but why are you
trying it's like it's like there's a
difference between that guy and the guy
that you know he's like he's it's
different bro yeah so like vice versa
there's no wrong time for the right guy
that's what i was that's what my point
is so two o'clock in the morning for the
right guy is the right time because it's
all about energy
is you're talking about that like most
guys know what energy is most most guys
see a bum bum and they're like oh great
energy i'm not thinking about no energy
they're thinking that looks nice they're
going to die from yeah
there you go like but that being said
so like
you should always like if it's like
you're the average guy you don't get you
don't be getting females regularly
like don't start off in the night start
off in the day
[Laughter]
i think that would be like much
and then
you wouldn't feel as unsafe because
there's light so people are gonna see
you know there are more people around
versus at night time what people are
really out
like
yeah that is a good point because like
all right because during the day like if
something happens
you like the most likely there's always
someone there to like help you
and it's like at night time like we're
always told like don't carry weapons and
things of that nature so obviously you
feel less secure at nighttime because
you're by yourself you have nothing to
defend yourself with
but
that being said like i'm not condoning
people that like try it out at night
time
it's just like
it's just feeling if the energy is right
yeah like obviously like yeah
you you won't be like accessible all the
time
now that's like a guarantee like you
know you're not gonna be accessible all
the time like it could be in the middle
of the day someone come up to you you
tell them to
get to get lost but at night time it's
kind of like
there's already like all these problems
that be happening so like you already
like shipped him off
as you're on high alert so ladies do you
think do you think right in your in your
life
you've rejected a man
in a way where you know you're trying to
make him feel small
like you know you get you know you get
those women that reject a man like i'm
gonna
did he even think is he crazy right but
you've given him that energy because
like i said when we're talking about the
red pool rage a lot of guys that have
tried
to approach women have been like shut
down in like the worst way
which has kind of fueled their anger
have you done that
i feel like
if someone's tried to and i've politely
tried to shut it down and they haven't
respected that then yeah i've probably
been firmer with it i wouldn't ever try
and intentionally make someone feel
small
or less than
but if i don't want to talk to you just
please respect that i don't want to talk
to you like i've said what i've said
like just leave it at that
do you think that a lot of guys are
sorry go on they just answer that do you
think you've shot a guy down like
i think pretty much the same like as far
as if they keep trying and trying and
then they get disrespectful with it then
i feel like maybe i put more bass in my
voice or i'll let you know like leave me
alone i feel like i try to be really
nice about it but people take your
kindness for weakness every day so it's
like let me let you know no i'm not
interested please move along and then
even when you say please it's like oh
that's a chance some people some guys
take that as a chance as you being nice
about it even though you're telling them
leave me alone it's like oh she said
please oh please that's a that's a
that's a weigh-in that's a maybe that's
amazing exactly but like in the case
like where like some females haven't
like came corr like having like came
like respectful do you not see like that
might add until like that guy is going
to like now have that hatred like he
came to a girl nicely and she was like
oh you're ugly you're broke you get no
money i think that's that's just why
you're really
do you not think that after that happens
maybe he's gonna stop being as nice he's
gonna go about like his life he's gonna
start like
acting less like normal around females
like he's gonna have like this thing
like where like in a case where like he
might end up doing great
ah oh hey that was a big jump jelly
extreme jump but i'm saying like maybe
like
there's no there's no excuse for there's
no excuse for great yeah i'm not saying
no whatsoever
on this show like this is pearl show and
i'm standing in we don't condone any
grape of moles molestation of any kind
under any circumstances
uh so
a guy you were saying like that gets
shot down like that
one of the reasons why i think um i
think this whole red pill rage thing is
multi-layered i think
there's a lot of guys that don't know
how to work on themselves
and
and i think a lot of men have lost their
purpose preach and so i think i always
speak to men and i say listen man find
your purpose stick on your purpose and
do that first because once you start
doing that things will kind of start
falling into place and i think because
like we're talking about men becoming
more feminine and women becoming more
masculine i feel like men
have
lost what it is to be a man and manly
and have a purpose they've been they
felt like they've had to become more
feminine a lot of guys didn't want to
you know i mean i think a lot of guys
didn't want to become more feminine and
i think
and i think a lot of
while guys became like feminine women
became more masculine and then they
started interacting and then the guys
are like well
if i
become more masculine in this situation
i
get looked up as the bad one like
masculinity became like a a bad thing
yeah do you know what i mean i think
masculinity became like a bad thing in
society which is why i think like
there's so much
anger and rage and i'm just saying guys
i get i understand the rage right i
understand the rage but we need to kind
of calm down a little bit and i think
there's a lot of guys out there that do
have a lot of rage and i understand why
but i just want to
guys calm down a little bit you know i
mean and i think on the women's side
women also need to learn to understand
that they have become more masculine in
the society the independence the boss
[ __ ]
the you know i can get what i want
whenever i want it and a lot of guys are
looking at that and just saying ah i'm
gonna go my own way because
i don't want to be around a woman like
that
do you know what i mean
um it's fine no
say it again that's fine no
no it's not fine why because we need men
and women to be together in order for
huma humanity to continue
like one time
so there's different types of men and
women like i think some men
not of course not all men but what if a
guy does want to just
maybe play a more feminine role as in
like stay at home while the woman goes
out to provide like there shouldn't be
anything wrong with that
and that like
vice versa like i don't know i just
don't think i think i think men like
respect
and i think um
men that want respect
understand that women generally if they
are doing the whole
house husband thing aren't going to be
as respected as a man who's not
do you know what i'm saying i'm not
saying that it's wrong any man that
chooses to do that good luck buddy you
go ahead and do it but i'm just saying
men generally like
the respect aspect of a relationship a
man can be respected in a relationship
because a man knows if he gains a
woman's respect
she's not going to go out elsewhere
once a woman loses respect for a man
she's gone
do you know what i mean and i'm talking
about mentally and emotionally but is it
more for a man to go out and provide is
that more of a male ego or is that
because that is really what they just
think what a woman wants i think that's
the way societies have always been built
it's how you like
this this this house
and societies get built by men that go
out and do things they they get built by
men who are masculine they don't get
built by society don't get built by men
that are feminine
the plumbing needs to be done the
mechanics needs to be done the houses
need to be built
the
things the trains need to be run like
those are ma those are what you would
call quote-unquote masculine men those
aren't the feminine ones
do you know do you know what i mean like
the feminine men aren't doing that
i would so for me i would say that's a
more masculine role in general i
wouldn't say that's just men i would say
that's more maybe masculine trait
i wouldn't say because i
like i i know
female boxers boxing's maybe considered
masculine i know female security that's
probably considered more masculine like
i think
but are they builders of society though
that's what i'm trying to say like
people have a role like that masculinity
has a role in society yeah and do you
think do you think security would be
um more or less effective if there was
more women being security
be honest i feel like men would be
obviously taken more seriously if they
were that's not why i'm asking
you no i'm saying would it be safer or
less safer by more women becoming
security and less men become a security
less safe
less safe because
there's there's rules for certain jobs
it's like
i would i wouldn't want my
daughter being taught by
a man kindergarten teacher
why why why
because that's my daughter because peter
files success so i'm sorry that you're
teenage a teacher
so is that
all men but that's the same way because
a woman can go after a little boy or a
little girl yeah yeah of course you see
that
it's less likely
i don't think it's less likely and i
think that also goes towards like men
aren't taking seriously when it comes to
abuse because i think it happens just as
much to men
mm-hmm exactly yeah but wait one day
you're saying oh the the male like i
wouldn't want the male teacher for my
daughter because he could go after her
the female teacher could go after the
child just as well
but it's less likely no who says that
because who says that a lot of a lot of
little boys are touched the same way
okay so statistically who's more likely
to to
like be involved in
sexual assault of a minor
both
men thank you but hang on we're going to
get to some super chats and then we're
going we're going to get back to this um
shenanigans
uh 10 super chat it's all about sexual
dating experience emotional intelligence
is just a pattern recognition with so
many men unable to get dates they aren't
able to learn where the line is
need experience to gain experience
okay so nighty free a freaked free to
pie 499 says ask them how they would get
a man if they didn't have a certain
female organ
how would they get a man with no
flour
um the tim narut 5 says from how the
woman in the blue is been talking most
of what she's saying is all lies you
need to be more truthful so you're liked
more stop the caps
[Laughter]
there's no problem with
man goals alone or woman goes along we
just need to we we just need the state
to stop get my money to to give it to
fem
i don't quite get that one um jc two
dollars little kim do a quick freestyle
for the show
i don't know about that oh okay right
now okay
um nighty fruity pie 4.99 says women
want the rules of their living room to
apply to the whole world all the time
with everyone
where's the women's super chats man come
on man yeah like we do need more days
well there were some impressions i feel
it's a bit one-sided isn't it
well one person said right
awesome how they would feel
if i'm gonna ask them how they would get
a man if they didn't have a certain
female organ well you know the bottom
line is men wouldn't be after women if
they didn't have a certain female organ
do you know what i mean
um
sorry you were talking before what were
you saying bro no because
because i don't want people to think
that i'm actually condoning
grape and that like i i'm probably the
one of the first person that will
probably save you do you know what i
mean like
but it's like i'm not gonna say if you
jump in the fire that you
you jumped out and just said you've been
burnt like i'm not gonna not
like
nurture your wounds or i'm not gonna not
do this like i'm a man like i feel i've
got seven sisters so what now do you
think so because you're saying this so
what now do you think women need to do
in general
in general this is what women need to do
they need to stop um giving up
uh their privates
for anything less than a ring
they need to stop
before they're six before marriage yeah
exactly how do you laugh at that but no
hang on hang on i'm not saying that's
unrealistic i'm saying how realistic
is that within these days and times i'll
tell you how realistic is
before before the girl
there's there's a girl right now sitting
down that hasn't had sex yet that's
watching this
do you know what i mean like it's it's
because she has had um people tell her
it's okay to do this i've too much
podcast i've watched when they've been
like yes okay go you do you black you've
got and it's like but you're coming from
another woman's perspective because
she's going through the same thing so
she only wants you to go through it
because she's going through it so now if
we have if the man has two holes to
choose from he's only got a hole to
choose from do you know what i mean so
it's like you're but that's you're going
against what the man actually wants it's
like a man is not saying to a woman
we're not going to give you what you
want you want you want a man that's
doing his own thing that has got his
money that's do you think i'm going to
do that you want a man that's going gym
that's doing that protecting you i'mma
do that do you want a man to look after
you and pay and go work and treat you
nice i'm gonna do that so do you think
now men need to wait as well to get a
ring to have sex then no because that's
what we want once we want sex no no i'll
tell you why we want sex but who are you
having sex with if the women are
supposed to be waiting for a marriage
exactly so if there is no woman for us
to have sex with we're going to get
married so you leave us no choice but to
get married but if there is woman that's
actively out there saying you could have
mine i'm not going to get married and
restrict myself to one woman am i it's
like why why why should i say you're
saying in the ideal world both men and
women would wait to get
wait for marriage 100
i also felt like with that like you
can't just learn
i also feel like with that you shouldn't
like go into a marriage solely because
of sex like initially because number one
okay the problem with that initially
like sex before marriage is because
compatibility like sometimes like no
it's because girls pair bond they don't
know like more women finished now like
compatibility is also something to
consider because like you wouldn't like
imagine you marry someone
and you have sex with them but it
doesn't work out how you want but then
you have sex with someone else
and everything just goes good so it's
about the sex then oh yeah but that's
only because you're saying like they
have to like have to get married first
and then have sex but like you know
the reason without having said yeah the
reason why i'm saying they should marry
first compatibility first like you can't
like i'm just like you know
marriage
is a dying art form right there right
now in any say sometimes so what i'm i'm
not saying that what you're saying is
wrong i'm saying what you're missing
is the fact that we're living in a
society where divorce rates are up
um
marriages and the way in which they're
going are down people less people are
getting married and it's like
it's like you saying oh yeah let's let's
bring back the 80s i don't hear that but
bro the a's are gone
at the same time the world's smaller so
you could if you want the world's
smaller so if you want to now you have
the choice but i don't want to live here
i could live in malaysia and i'll go
find a wife in malaysia there's a woman
that's sitting down there waiting to be
taken she would to take me this marist
is in the west in the western world the
west right so we could take a plane take
a plane go to where you want to find
where you're what is a girl goes to find
what she wants she's getting food out
because she wants to enjoy wherever
she's at go flight fly out and find out
why are you saying that men should go
elsewhere than the western world 100
million 29 million
leave these girls let them
be independent by themselves bro like
you can't come to me when you're 45
years old and tell me now you want to
marry bro
when you was 20 you didn't want to know
me
now i'm now you all on me no i'm all
right i have a question do you consider
yourself average
yes super average why do you consider
yourself super average because
i haven't got
a certain amount of money in my bank
account
i haven't got like um a beautiful wife i
haven't got
to the place where i want to in terms of
my career
i haven't got the size in terms of my
muscular in terms of um my muscles in
terms of where i want to be so i'm super
average but me being super average is
still like uh eight nine for london it's
like what i mean like
i have no trouble finding women trust me
and i'm average i know i'm average
no but i'm just asking because i feel
like you say that your average sometimes
plays into how you see things as far as
you're talking about
women and how you approach them and you
said you know you were talking about us
wearing skirts or us wearing leggings
and leaving nothing to the imagination
and stuff like that but i'm like
thinking to myself like do you consider
yourself but men are more realistic with
their average status yeah
generally i think men understand when
they when they know they're average
right
i think women that are average kind of
don't know
act like they're more so like
like and that is one of the reasons why
kevin samuels used to say you know what
do you look like when you step out of
the shower fresh face no makeup just
like that
and a lot of people like i'm a tan it's
like come on love let's be honest you
know what i mean like let's just be
honest so it's like yeah so the average
status i think men are more um
realistic with their average stayers
like expect the man to be who you want
your son to be like you know what i mean
like you don't want your son to be with
no like
like girl that has four four kids from
four different
um baby fathers that's done nothing with
her life that just
gold digs or like you wouldn't want that
for your son you wouldn't you don't want
us to be independent either i do want
you i don't i don't care if you're
independent or not i'm just saying that
if you've changed the rules of marriage
then expect me to like
evolve you can't expect me to stay the
same like and keep like putting my coat
down on the floor for you to walk over
and then you go with jamal ken harry and
and david like for free
you know what you sound like you sound
like you are done with western women
yeah for for relationships yeah not for
sexual acts
because i i love it i love western world
women for that i love it they're the
best they don't require you to give them
nothing
they don't require you to give them
nothing they you just just be honest
just meet them in the club and like you
got a bottle with you you're right
you're okay calm you could talk to them
all right you'll be all right you got a
little pecks on you you're all right you
drive a little car you all right they
don't require much
when they start require i'm not saying
that it's a bad thing i'm just saying
when you start requiring more men will
start stepping up can we always follow
what woman is doing i don't know why
women are men men
no you know you what you what a woman's
worth is you know what you you know how
you could change a whole room by just
walking in it do you know what i mean
you know the power of a woman so why
would you just give it up like well
don't give it up yeah like as a society
like i think what he's trying to say is
that we need to separate city goals from
independent women yeah they're kind of
conjoined right now like when you think
of like a strong independent woman you
think of like kyb and like she'd be
preaching like do dc ghost stuff
but however as an independent strong
independent woman like you also have to
like respect yourself enough to like not
give yourself to anyone like you have to
be like inclusive like yo like
diamonds are more valuable than gold
because they're rarer to get
fair enough so if we're being rare in
diamonds right
um
what are you guys doing as far as you
guys say
you guys go for the western girls
because you can have sex with them and
it's no big deal and you can just have
bottles and stuff like that and that's
what he's saying
one time sorry that's what you said and
i'm asking myself well what are you
gonna bring to the table why are you
gonna be a diamond and you know you say
okay you're talking about the whole sex
and marriage you're talking about women
should stop giving it up so once we
start giving it up you're only gonna go
for those women that are giving it up to
you i'm a match
okay
are you gonna let me put it this way
like men when we normally see a girl
that we like and know straight away that
we like her
like like you
it's
i don't have to talk to you to like you
in that sense like i can see attraction
i see it i know what i want like boom
that's that's fire it's very unlikely
that you would be like that
do you understand it's very unlikely
that you would be like to answer your
question what are men bringing right
when men focus when men focus on their
purpose and when men be who they are and
when men stand in their masculinity
women
find them
men don't have to find women if they're
in their if they're in and on their
purpose and the way they're supposed to
be because
women
see just like we go back to that 80 20
thing all the women look at that guy
like who is who's that guy
who's that
80 of women are looking at that guy so
for me
um i think men need to
stand within themselves understand
themselves get on their purpose
find their hobby find who they are and
then in general
women will
see them
okay can i ask you something yeah so
check this out yeah
most women i find when they when they're
working and independent they normally
stop stop that independent stuff when
they when it comes to who they're
choosing so when i say that they would
they're not gonna say i'm independent so
i want like a broke guy no she wants a
guy that's making as much as her or more
than her a woman will always break her
rules for the wac for the right man
right so so he he has to be making more
than her anyway so let's say no
no no because she will break those rules
for the right man all right but
there's exceptions to every rule but
we're saying in general when women are
looking for men they're looking for a
man that's me that's making a bit more
than them all like on the same level for
a long-term partner yeah for a long-term
partner but she's like you know women
that have i know you probably know women
that are making quite a bit and they're
dealing with some waste guy yeah because
he's laying good pipe yeah definitely do
you know what i'm saying so but
so the bottom line is right
she broke all her rules for the right
man and that's the man that's driving
her car yeah he's driving her car she's
he's living in her house
she's cooking for him and she's thinking
what the hell am i doing but he's laying
good pipe she got attracted to him and
so but she don't upgrade him
let's be very clear oh sorry uh this
isn't an exception to the rule this is
the rule breaker yeah because an
exception to the rule means that we
don't use that as a rule of thumb
but we are saying that in this instance
if this is the right guy
she'll break all our rules she will
break the rule yeah this is a rule
breaker not an exception to the rule for
how long though like so okay i'll show
you it for life no no no no no no no
trying to change him
trying to change him she's she's
undecisive so what would happen i'll
tell you what would happen she would
stay for him for a limited amount of
time until she fixes up and the next guy
comes along that is that is doing what
she would do it for life trying to
change him into the man that she looks
at in her head
women see potential
exactly
you're saying this but everyone's saying
the same thing when i say that you see
potential but you're not helping out the
man so in the sense of this you'll be
like all right i i'm gonna be with the
guy that's making less than me but i'm
not gonna put him in a situation where
he's making more than me why would he
need help if he's getting everything he
needs with less i'll tell you why
there are guys in a woman's house right
now ain't got no place to live yeah
chilling ain't got no plan
probably got about five kids on the
street
right eating the children eating her
children's um snacks right
and
he's just laying good pipe and he's
chill he's thinking that's all i gotta
do he's just all right cool so
it doesn't exist but i'm not saying
that's the that's not the general rule
of thumb like it's not common knowledge
for a total two women
like no that's not that's not normal
there's a lot of women out there with
men laying up in their crib yeah
of course
you said like they're gonna fix up
if they fix up and you're still doing
the same thing you're going to be left
in the past exactly bro
that's my point no you don't you guys
stop listening wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
let me feel like if you're getting by
eating the [ __ ] kids gummy snacks and
not doing [ __ ] and you're getting
everything you need why why am i gonna
do better if i'm getting everything i
want with doing less yeah i was about to
go it makes no sense like obviously it
would it would be ideal it would be
better for the woman for the guy to fix
up but no why why the hell was she
because she's getting the perfect world
it's good for her it's working for both
of them so there's no need for either
one of them to fix so do you so hang on
you're telling me that the woman who's
got the
the random wasteman on her couch right
or in her house it's working for her she
doesn't want better for herself no
because obviously you're saying that
like he's laying the good pipe or
whatever whatever is the reason that
he's getting by what he's doing is
working for her no that's true that
labour is
look usually something happens something
changes within the relationship he's
either he stops doing something
and that's the reason why she leaves but
here's the thing
she will always in some instances she
will go back
and it's you gotta understand being an
average man and being a top 20
you see things differently
and i'm not saying just see things
differently you actually experience
things differently the average man may
experience a woman
um
like
ignoring him as such and things like
this the top 10 guy might
see a woman in her darkest form like
willing to risk do it relationships
trust me as a guy
who i wouldn't even put myself in the
top 20
but as a guy
you know
when you've lived a certain way and
you've seen certain things i've i've
been in situations and i've been like
average guys don't do they don't get
this
do you know what i'm saying and i know
that as a guide you know what i'm saying
so i can look and say you know what when
i was
in my i don't know teens 20s or whatever
this wasn't happening but certain things
start to happen as you get older when
you start to kind of understand the game
and understand how people think and all
this kind of stuff so
yeah
i ain't going to say anything
quickly
like you can have everything they want
but unless you show it as soon as they
as soon as they see you
you're not gonna have that opportunity
like
like say like she wants someone who's
stable like if you don't come across as
a stable person she's not to come
through and be like oh yeah he's got
potential no but she's saying he's
saying that they break the rules for
that person but the thing women always
break the rules for the right guys
but for how long though is what my point
is like they they would break the rules
yes i'm not saying that they wouldn't
but when when she's she's she very
quickly snaps out of it like do you know
what i mean like she would be with that
guy for a little bit quickly yeah do you
step out
no it's nice
you underestimate women's delusion
factor okay you reckon yes
women will stay in years of relationship
with a guy that she knows that ain't
doing a goddamn thing
for her because she wants to change that
man
women's delusion factor is crazy bro
jada smith please yeah but in the
potential they don't they like okay so
you know how just how i normally see it
yeah
if i'm if there's five jobs
and
before when when it was like um
before feminism and stuff the the five
roles for the five jobs would be done by
five men
yeah those five men would have five
wives yeah yes so that's ten people
eating from those five jobs yeah now
we're in a world where two of those jobs
or three of those jobs goes to the woman
yeah and two or three goes to the man
yeah
the woman is not taking the man out of
poverty like how the same way how the
one of the five guys is doing it i agree
yeah but when you say you're saying it
like oh she's letting him sleep on the
couch and drive the car and stuff no
it's different to when a man's with a
woman that's not doing it and providing
then when a woman's being the provider
because i've been in a relationship
where my girl makes more than me and she
still expected me to to pay for dates
she still expected me to that's two
different things
in what sense because you're saying that
you're working we're talking about the
bum that's not doing [ __ ] and it's able
i'm not talking about just bums i'm
talking about any guy you you want a guy
who's making as much as you or more than
you but that wouldn't be an exception
like
that's what women look for they look for
a guy that's making that right
yeah women look for a guy that's making
more generally but i'm saying the woman
will have
all of these criteria i'm looking for a
guy who's making more he's gotta be this
whatever it is
but they will break those rules for the
right guys and a lot of those guys know
that they're the rule breakers for women
right which is why they got multiple
women and which is why they got multiple
which is why they got multiple babies
with multiple women perfect and which is
why a lot of women find themselves
getting into situations fighting with
other baby mothers that they know
shouldn't it be fun but because that i
said before earlier on the show there's
something about that guy yeah there's
something about that guy that all the
women want the rule breaker guys exist
and i think a lot of women are going for
rule breaker men instead of um
two twofold actually i think a lot of
women's criteria is
too much personally and then what
happens is because they've deluded
themselves with this criteria really and
truly
that guy that is going to be sleeping on
your couch that's the guy that you
probably want that's a one that you find
exciting do you know what i mean so all
of those rules and regulations that you
have for these guys
women i think you should really like
review them
just review them like i think a lot of
the time it's unrealistic
a lot of women are batting outside the
stratosphere where they should be
you know here on earth
not necessarily okay it's like saying to
a man here don't don't aim for that girl
that you want
like just go for a lesser girl i'm not
really saying that to women i'm saying
if you want that kind of man then you
need to go if you need like in the sense
of the the other way around for me i'll
be like bro i'm not gonna say i'm not
gonna get her and just give up no i'm
going to go gym i'm going to try and
increase my wealth i'm going to try and
make myself a better catch for her
as opposed to like saying i'm not good
enough do you know what i mean like so
when i said i must like an average guy
like you know i mean i can be an above
average guy but would you not want to do
that for yourself not just for someone
else no that's why because i'm when i
was when i was born i innately had that
feeling where i needed to protect and
look after our family like that's what
men are actually raised up to it's like
you one day you're gonna have a wife
that you're gonna have to look after
you're gonna have to treat her nice men
are always taught how to treat women
nice like you're gonna have to do this
for her you have to do that are women
too how to treat men nice
yeah
yeah i do think that uh even if women
are not taught to treat men nicely i
think women are taught to be like a maid
in that sense like
the
the submissive role as a wife would be
like you know you need to clean you need
to cook where it's like a son could get
by he doesn't listen most women nowadays
don't know how to cook rice
they haven't had to cook rice they've
got a rice cooker
all right they don't know how to write
so i don't i don't know if women are
generally i think men are generally told
to be more traditional but i think women
are kind of
told to be less traditional
and is that is that to do with like
single mothers
you know what i'm saying i agree with
that
and they feel like being more
traditional is
oh my god you're going to be taken over
by the patriarchy and he's going to be
he's going to take advantage of the
misogyny he's going to get you and
he's going to take all your [ __ ]
that's what i think women are taught
nowadays to fear
to fear a man
who is more traditional because or
to fear her traditional role
so she doesn't get
i guess done over in the end i think
it's more a case of being seen as more
than just her traditional role
men men are not seen as more than a
traditional role that's that's one of
the double standards i think that that
comes in that you're undervaluing what
like the role of a woman was
undervaluing yeah you're undervaluing it
so like you i would say that a man going
out to work is equally as important as a
woman looking after the household
right you know what i mean when i say
that i mean like you can't undervalue
you keeping the house clean because it
keeps us all healthy you can't
undervalue you feeding me because that's
what the energy i need to go out and
work even harder
but why can't we both go out to work
because if we both because i we have
roles so it's either i go out and do it
or you go out and do it because over
time
we figured out that's the best way to do
it why can't we just both do it no you
don't understand men like men have like
this thing in them when they see their
woman doing certain things it's like
just like women have it in men like when
they see men doing certain things like
you know that sometimes women see a man
like putting together a shelf and
they're like
or whatever it is whatever it is that
you see a man doing and you're like um
yeah that's manly like men have the same
thing so when a man sees a woman do
certain things that are in there
feminine
like
cooking like i love watching a woman
cook love it
i'm like and that's for me
yeah
that's what i'm like why'd you not hate
it so it's like i'm like i love it you
cook for me and my belly's full like
the world is yours you know like yeah
it's the oyster like right you know what
that is right yeah
right
that's what we do
that's how we are
women are trying to run over but hang on
let's get some super chats first because
we're going to win a close out soon um
93 of pies 4.99 says i know
men wouldn't but please ask the girls
how would they keep a man
if they didn't have a flower
okay
aisha
examines 999 says there are different
pro progressivity sorry
proclivities that men and women have it
seems like the women think men
and women have interchangeable roles in
society third world countries
continually prove otherwise
um
is that it down i scroll down yeah
uh
hang on
hang on yeah uh brian nelson
ten dollars women overwhelmingly date
and marry across or up
very very rarely down
saying they break the rules for the
right guy is disingenuous that's the
exception and the small minority female
hypergamy thank you they might not be
married thank you
because that
uh there's no problem if a man goes
alone a woman no i read that one i think
and there's no problem with the man
going on a woman go alone we just need
to stay
stop get my money to give it to fem
i think i read that one last time um
yeah guys
girls
amazing uh closing statements please um
from
from what you've heard today
we go around
what we heard today was first of all we
have to de-power like see woman
and we also have to realize that
if we want to find the woman that we
want to find
we're going to have to take risks but do
it appropriately
um in general i think
we all need to be more realistic
about what we want and
just
work on ourselves i think um
and
yeah just
be realistic
to be honest
as a matter of fact before we go around
again where can people find you if they
need to see
you're into your socials your insta
oh yeah i go by really miso on instagram
um budge underscore here underscore so
doj
okay
it's final thoughts what are your
thoughts today
um i think it's just it depends on what
you're looking for as female male
whomever and it's what you're willing to
deal with and who and how they act or
whatever it's basically what you're
gonna do what you're dealing with what
you want as far as everything making
people find you uh no worries brown
instagram
final thoughts um i think
just being realistic and also knowing
what works for you because what works
for the next man doesn't inherently work
for yourself
um
and
my youtube is in the description nice
um i would say
to have these conversations yourself at
home i think these this conversation was
so enlightening just to hear so many
different perspectives even if we didn't
like agree necessarily on certain things
it's still so important to have them and
i've taken that away learning of a
different people's perspective and where
they come from it
and i just think more people should have
that at home as well within their own
circles okay where can where can the
people to fight you um i am i am
isabella johnson on all socials
final thoughts um
i i loved it i i wish you guys would
challenge me more because like i know do
you know what i mean
it's not that like i'm so confident
about how i think but i love of other
people when they're confident and how
they think when it
challenges how i think do you know what
i mean like people i know people a lot
of people think i don't like
confrontation in that sense but i like
it man
i love it so where can we find you
everywhere man
it's everywhere man youtube facebook
twitter instagram bebo myspace tick tock
grinder msn live view ball right now
back in the day your name
yeah they're gonna they're gonna want to
know how they find it my name is amiri
but um yeah you find me man all right uh
folks guys and girls thank you for
tuning in today again if you haven't
already subscribed or liked or shared
you know do that right now click on the
notification button please so you are so
you know when we next go live um and my
name is pearl
it is i'm joking my name is sarah garvey
um you can find me in the
description
and i shall see you
next week
bye